video has surfaced
of the biden administration smuggling
migrant children into tennessee and many
other southeastern states
and i was a bit red is it to say
smuggling but i'm like that's
actually what he's doing a lot of these
news outlets are like secretly
transporting
illegal immigrant children into these
states without their knowledge
and i'm like that's extremely verbose
for smuggling which means to convey
secretly or illicitly which is what the
body administration is doing right now
they screwed up the border so bad
and they are so desperate they're
literally just putting kids on planes
and flying them out to random places
well tennessee politicians are really
really angry like yo what are you doing
this is crazy it is crazy it's extremely
crazy
we got some other stories too the the
lab leak stuff is now
going mainstream politifact apparently
now
has semi-rescinded a fact check claiming
that the covet lab leak hypothesis was
debunked
because now they're like okay well it's
not debunked they're
they're undebunking is that a word
mm-hmm un-debunking
politifact that's undebunked they're
bunking they're they're banking
i think it's a rebound all right so the
lablic hypothesis has been has
been rebunked by politifact and uh we
definitely got to talk about it
so joining us today is will chamberlain
of human events
how's it going um i am will chamberlain
the co-publisher
and i don't know exactly what my editor
title is we still need to figure that
out but i run the opinion side
there you go um and i also am senior
counsel at the internet accountability
project the article 3 project and
something new
the unsilenced majority which is a new
canceled culture group
um where you can't so so a cancel
culture anti-anti-cancer it's like
you're trying
although although we do sort of are
willing to cancel people who use cancer
culture which is in
my view perhaps the most justified use
of cancer yeah it's like using a
flamethrower and a guy with a
flamethrower yeah
there you go there you go that's allowed
um and you know
yeah and we hired we heard jack the soap
today which i'm really happy about
events
um you know that was announced on on
twitter and
we're stoked i mean jack in my view is
not only a very good personal friend but
a very good journalist in his own right
and he doesn't get credit for it i mean
he had he had scoops on the mueller
investigation that no one else had and
they were confirmed by the new york
times three weeks later
he's also a secret agent in a comic book
yes there you go
he's a really cool guy yes he's a really
good guy
he wears a suit so i just assumed he was
like stodgy but then i met him and i was
like i love you dude
it's like you i mean i maybe i the
problem i gained some weight so i'm not
wearing a suit properly but i had like
nice custom suits and
oh cool you gotta drop some weight i
know yeah that's what i got to do
we got we got ian oh yeah ian crossland
what's up guys uh you can always find me
in crossland.net but i'm happy to be
here very good i will also sing jack's
praises
he's an awesome friend he's a cool
source he always has really neat scoops
and i'm excited
for he's part of human events now before
we get started you gotta go to
timcast.com
click the blue members only button and
then
sign up you can choose stripe or paypal
that will give you access to the members
only
area where we have exclusive segments
just for our members
my friends we are going to have a very
special creepy
eerie donald trump future time travel
bonus segment tonight it delves into the
weird
and wild and conspiracies it's going to
blow your mind mark my words you will
have a laugh
and some people probably will
unfortunately end up believing this
stuff but there's a really crazy story
that's been around for some time we're
going to get into so you got to go to
timcast.com and sign up don't forget
like and subs like this video subscribe
to this channel
but more importantly share the show
right now do it share with your friends
take the url put on facebook or twitter
or whatever else you can
and uh help help spread the word so
that's the the word of mouth is the best
way to
support the show let's jump into this
first story
which uh honestly i couldn't believe
from wrcb-tv
nbc late night flights carrying migrant
children
arrive in chattanooga chattanooga's
wilson air center is receiving planes
carrying migrant children
who are being bussed to multiple
southeastern cities
during overnight hours let me just
simplify it for you
this is the bite administration
smuggling migrant children
into this into the central us into these
southeastern states and cities
they say channel three obtained video of
one of those planes a raving
arriving friday may 14th shortly before
1 30 a.m
a second video shared with channel 3
shows more children arriving late
saturday night
according to the source who provided the
video a third plane
carrying children arrived friday
afternoon flight records confirmed that
a fourth plane arrived early wednesday
morning may 19th
this is this is amazing did anybody
approve this does anybody know about
this
i mean i'm sure it was approved by
someone in the department of homeland
security
uh you can bet that after the kids in
cages debacle
um with you know like the five-fold
increase in illegal immigration to start
the term
that somebody in the bite administration
was told that under no circumstances
were there to be more photos of kids
piled up in cages with space blankets
so so now they got videos of kids being
shuffled into planes and flown out to
random cities
i mean probably probably better
optically oddly enough
right like if we're just trying to avoid
the really you know image that will
disturb
uh joe biden voters it would be the one
of them being
near the border so out of sight out of
mind right as long as they're
this is i'm sorry man this is
apocalyptically bad in my opinion this
is
a hundred-fold worse than kids in cages
they're just like okay we don't want the
kids to be in the cages so
put them on a plane fly him at tennessee
put him on a bus and ship off to a group
home
everything about the biden policy it's
like the maximum amount of immorality
that you could do with immigration
policy right like
if they had done open borders that would
be less immoral right and if they had
gone
full border closure that would be less
immoral they have managed to find the
uncanny valley of the worst
possible policy which is again i mean so
in in tort law there's something called
i don't know if i talked about this
before but attractive nuisance
um no what is that uh so attractive
nuisance
you know normally if somebody trespasses
on your land and gets hurt you're not
liable they trespassed
but if you have something on your land
like a broken merry-go-round or
something what about an apple tree or
who knows it could be anything but like
something that attracts children yeah
right and you attract leads the children
to trespass and they get hurt
even though they're trespassing you are
liable that's bs
wow but i knew i knew about this because
i'm a skateboarder
so uh we at the mini ramp back in philly
we had we had a no skateboarding sign on
it
so we're like no trespassing and then no
skateboarding allowed right
so so attractive nuisance basically uh
our border is an attractive nuisance
right the promise of
getting you know citizenship or the
ability to work in the united states is
what attracts people and the nuisance
part is
the fact that people are having to go
through this unbelievably difficult
journey in order to get it
right they're you know crossing you know
finding themselves in the hands of drug
cartels and human traffickers
uh going through very dangerous journeys
crossing the rio grande all this sort of
nonsense
um so we're responsible i guess yeah
like the the bite administration i think
no i mean
the trump administration had the cr you
know a much more moral policy which is
actual deterrence right right like
australia had a similar donation
remember remember when trump said he
wanted moats full of alligators
yeah i'm kidding he didn't really say
that but they claimed he did that's good
enough i mean
it is moral to deter people from
engaging in a dangerous journey
didn't it talk about like lasers or
something too yeah sure i mean
you know australia had this problem when
they had boat people coming from like
fiji and
and islands surrounding it and they had
all these drownings right tons of
drownings in the
in the boats off of australia and they
said they just had a huge policy it's
like if you get here on a boat you're
not gonna be able to stay
period and stop change law what if you
have a merry-go-round
and a mouth full of alligators if the
kids fall in the muffle of alligators
is it a nuisance or deterrent like am i
in trouble i don't think attractive
nuisance would come into play that would
probably
be still a crime uh i would say so
because you're you know there's there's
i don't remember exactly what the law is
but you're not for example you can't set
up like trap guns in your house
you can see the alligators bro like i
understand that you can see them but
like the idea is you can't set up like
intentionally fatal traps
on your property because you will be
liable if someone kills themselves
interesting so move to florida where
there's naturally occurring modes full
of alligators
look i i don't think the naturally
occurring mozzarella of alligators
that's a
good liability question are you do you
have to remediate that i don't know i
don't know the answer to that well well
anyway more to the point uh
i this is this is crazy i you know i
knew biden his policies were in the
gutter
and everything was falling apart but
this is a whole new level of bad it's
like
in the middle of the night taking these
unaccompanied children
and shuffling them off to who knows
where how insane
so so not only did joe biden create a
poll factor
by getting rid of donald trump's
remaining mexico uh policies so now it's
like come on in catch and release
these some of the many of these people
who had coveted were being released in
texas
when american citizens couldn't even
legally cross the border
then joe biden reopens the homestead
facility
look i get it you got a bunch of kids
you created a problem you need a place
to put them but let's be real
trump shut that facility down they were
complaining about it
joe biden's attractiveness was
attractive attractive nuisance yes
pulled these people it created a poll
factor which we we've heard about in the
news over and over again
so he reopens the the child
concentration camps
aoc's words now mine and then he expands
the mcallen facility so now he's got a
bunch of kids sleeping in the dirt
that's bad and now because the videos
are bad enough
and there's still more kids coming just
shuffle them off who knows where
that's that's that's all that's that's
depravity when you said pole factor you
mean like it's pulling people in
yeah so when people shut up with shirts
saying please let us in biden
donald trump was like you can't come to
our border we'll shut it down no
no excuse me you stay in mexico they're
like people get scared
if we try and go we'll get arrested and
then sent back and people were worried
that if they went from like you know
bolivia or something or colombia they'd
come up get sent back
all the way to south america and they're
like it's probably better staying just
in tijuana or something
with joe biden he's like come on man we
gotta get rid of these these policies
you know trump he's a nazi and so then
he gets rid of them all
and then people start rushing the border
again now it's created a massive
surge it's it's happening what like two
months earlier
so joe biden tried claiming it's
seasonal it's just seasonal migration
and it's like bro this is two months
earlier than seasonal migration no
you've created a pole factor your
policies are awful
trump had it had it functioning not
perfectly it spiked huge
under trump but they had policies and
they were pushing back
body makes it worse this is man
it's not seasonal it's global economic
the economy is is trembling
and people are fleeing their their south
american homeland
a lot of people are not even just south
america i saw an article that said like
you had european
economic migrants african economic
migrants crossing the southern border
all right and that's what it is i mean i
saw that like
there was some article that tried to be
like people refugees from countries hard
hit by covid i'm like no
no no that's not a refugee no no no
that's a migrant an economic right
and they're not fleeing they're
migrating yeah they're migrating like
well i suppose the easiest thing you can
do is put them on buses and planes and
just uh
yeah in a way it makes sense like
they're clearing up the space although
but the problem then is they're doing it
they try to seem like they want to do it
covertly yeah it's called smuggling yeah
which is illicitly transporting people
i made mention earlier that it sounds
like they're it's a conspiracy like
they would be charged with conspiracy
because they're they're transporting
known illegal immigrants across state
borders
i mean aiding and abetting criminals i
mean you know
there's almost certainly some sort of
affirmative defense doing so under color
of law
with the short order you know order from
the executive branch there's some
probably some statutory authority
you you know that we already have kids
in like orphanages and group
group homes who need loving parents and
are being tossed about the system
the last thing we need is forbidden to
screw everything up and then just
shuffle people under the rug that's
that's sickening it's just why we don't
like democrats it's like why responsible
people don't don't let democrats run
things well that's
why this is so important yeah but come
on man
the the republican party i tweeted
we need a commission of medical experts
and scientists to figure out
how several invertebrates and
terrestrial land
terrestrial snails somehow managed to
imitate english speech
join the republican party and get
elected murder rates yes
yes yeah yeah i mean we're talking about
january 6 commission in 30.
35. but come on it's not even that i
mean mitch mcconnell pretends to fight
look at what's going on because of the
fecklessness of the republican party
now i get it a speed bump is better than
nothing
but that's what republican party is at
this point they're a speed bump for
democrats
oh democrats got to slow down a little
bit they're making too much money oh i
can't stand
these people i want to lose faith in the
system i don't want to lose faith in
the american government because that
could be the beginning of the end
or the end of the end of the system but
they're they're they're making so much
money smuggling kids in that just
talking to each other every day and not
getting much done is enough for them
the democrats are beholden to zealots
the the the
republicans let's see let's be real no
no no no way absolutely not
they they they kick out their zealots
steve king he gets booted from all of
his committees and then he loses his
primary because nobody wanted to hear
what he had to say you're right
democracy
and omar gets protected by by nancy
pelosi so the democrats
for for for what it's worth they got
spines in spades
they will scream at the top of their
lungs they will bang on the doors of the
supreme court
they will storm into the senate
buildings and the media does nothing why
because their friends have spines and
media got the jobs took over the
institution
the institutions and protect them is it
always been like this
it's just now their social media so we
see it
i mean to a degree uh you know there was
a time when there was
there was actual like public cachet and
being republican and i think the iraq
war really destroyed that
right like the i'd say that you know
2000 era i mean
still republicans weren't like the
majority and dominant in the culture but
at least
like didn't they didn't they lose the
congress for like 40 years
yeah they did but yeah i mean it was it
was really bad for
a while but then i mean that's all very
you know it's a very different country
in that democratic coalition looks very
different
you know than than i just i just look at
where we're at right where we're at
right now with
democrats and ill and omar can just
shriek and they're like whatever you say
and the republicans just go okay and
then marjorie taylor greens like two
years ago posted some dumb stuff on
facebook and they're like get rid of
banner from everything she didn't even
say those things while she was a member
of congress yeah something like and a
bunch of republicans flipped you know
went over on that one too i mean we had
something like a dozen republicans
decide they were gonna vote
you know against their own member having
committee
seats the republican party is the
jellyfish party it's just you i mean
so many of these people need to be
replaced and and bullied
more effectively like there's there's a
lack of bullying yes avoided
like people need to show up and protest
these 35 jellyfish
yeah or are they just the oligarch party
no no no
the republicans i think are like uh do
you ever see
the way this is why i described it
earlier you ever see the movie this is
the end
no i hear it's great though i've seen it
so uh danny mcbride gets kicked out of
the house
and then later on they find him and he's
a cannibal and then he has he has that
actor i can't remember the
actor's name james franco's in it yeah
seth rogan's in it but that's all i know
he has that
that actor what's that actor's name he
was in g.i joe
you know what i'm talking about no
negative chad something i can't remember
his name
but he's a [ __ ] so he's like on all
fours and crawling around
and danny mcbride is a cannibal that's
the republican party is the [ __ ]
in the in the in this in the suit you
know and danny was right at the
democratic party it is shelled out now
now to be fair like they're like 10
republicans that are fighters
you know donald trump was a fighter
donald trump grabbed the party and
yanked it really hard
and that's what people liked so i
tweeted i tweeted something like the
republican party or jellyfish
and then i got a response from someone
who said all right i said uh
yeah they said the republican party
attracts the losers and i said
that's right if somebody wanted to lie
cheat and steal to gain power
they wouldn't pick the republican party
they'd get the democratic party you know
so
that's effectively what we're seeing is
that the people
who are manipulative and deceitful and
evil join the democrats and then just
burn things down and strip and extract
and manipulate the ignorant
it's real easy to get a vote when you're
democrat you go up to somebody and say
hey
i'll give you his money and they're like
deal and the republicans are like
personal responsibility you got to work
hard in meritocracy i'm like
that sounds like work so people vote for
not work
so you end up with a republican party
that's just like
a speed bump that no one's fighting for
anything
what what what are they fighting for
other than democrats don't do that
democrats don't you do that yeah what do
you stand for
for a long time this has been a
long-term frustration i mean i remember
trying to push for social media
regulation because like we obviously
needed it the dem
companies were controlled by the
democrats they were censoring
conservatives
and they're like well no but the free
market it's like okay
i mean and now every you know two years
later when we've lost power everybody's
like oh that was a good idea well we
should totally have done that
um you know we can't count on them can't
count on we're seeing some
i mean i'm seeing some good signs with
some of them like you know we'll get
into the seas the endowments
thing that cotton later tom cotton's
doing that tom cotton well he's gonna
tax them so you know a step in the right
direction um
you know taxation is theft sees it right
exactly like
i like i like to seize language we'll
get into that later i get worked up
about freedom like free trade
uh free free market free
freedom because it's not doesn't mean
that there's no interference
if you know the reason that we have a
free society is because we interfere
with it
we create order we create police that
say you can't walk there
at this time stay there don't do this do
this don't do this
so now we have freedom as a result
you're not going to get jumped and
murdered when you're walking around so
you're essentially
free no doesn't mean that it has no
rules so this the free market is the
same way if you don't put place rules on
the system
you get run away by by that logic prison
is freedom
that's not true well a prisoner has
a sort of freedom health care guaranteed
food right they have
a place to live that's not they're not
going to get technically they're not
going to get jumped and murdered because
the guards are they're watching them
well they're not supposed to because the
guards are
not freedom the rules don't make you
free it gives you
to be responsible for yourself no it
doesn't yeah i think the united states
bro they ban guns they lost the law the
law of the land though gives us an
opportunity to create freedom for
ourselves
if there was no law it wouldn't we would
not be in a free society some some laws
make sense and a lot of them don't
yes i definitely agree with that let me
tell you what we're seeing right now
this migrant thing is bad but i'll tell
you how bad it gets
this is another huge story honestly i
didn't know which story to lead with
because we got a bunch of just psychotic
stories
tulsa residents won't be able to pay
utility bills for three weeks
after ransomware attack like colonial
pipeline outage
and its claimed insurance giant cna paid
40 million dollar extortion fee tulsa
officials said the city system was also
targeted by ransomware
that hack means residents won't be able
to pay utilities for three weeks now may
be a good thing for those residents
i assume once the three weeks kicks back
on they're still going to owe all that
money
maybe even with late fees i wouldn't be
surprised they say it comes after
colonial pipeline admitted to paying a
4.4 million dollar ransom
it's amazing leadership i'm glad that
the fbi is trying to find that fat guy
in the wrigly shirt from january 6
and we got our cities being attacked by
hackers and shutting down our utilities
bravo good sirs keep keep keep it up and
we'll find out who that fat guy in the
trump hat is that guy should go to jail
right
was he the hacker no he's just some fat
guy who walked in the building dude so
who is the c
what are they called c cna and this is a
financial
company that paid out 40 million to 40
million dollar extortion fee
it's gonna keep happening because
as lydia pointed out in that instagram
video the russian
military commercial is like it's all
dark and it's like
you know speaking i can't know what
they're saying in russian but it's like
a guy and he's like looking with his
brow down and they jump out with
parachutes and they land on the ground
and they got bolt-action rifles for some
reason i don't know they're using
bolt-action sure
and uh then it switches to the american
one and it's like a disney cartoon about
two moms or something it's like
that's what america presents to the
world it's just
it's like in this sort of self-obsession
they're so obsessed with the internal
dynamics of their companies and
institutions that they forget that
they're there to like
perform a function in our society and be
competent at it uh
and i mean you know we can talk about
how wokeness is toxic in any number of
ways but one of them is this just
fundamental distraction from the core
mission that these people like
i don't want to hear about i don't care
about your identity
if you're working for the fbi i want to
hear that you're stopping
ransomware attacks yes so this is the
problem you talk about the rules
and the rules are supposed to create
freedom they don't what happens is they
create rules
and then the zealots who gain control of
the institutions enforce them against
their enemies
meanwhile these hacks are happening and
where's where's our law enforcement
where where's our where's cyber command
to be defending us to allow us to live
in that beautiful freedom we're supposed
to get
with our taxpayer dollars going to these
institutions instead they get shut down
i get it it's hard to defend against
these things but don't come to me
complaining with the fat guy in a trump
hat
and then and then creating a 911 style
commission on january 6
when you can't defend your own cities um
who hacked do they have any ideas
where they were from or anything i don't
know
it makes me think that they just don't
have the probably the same group
we don't know for sure we know that
darkseid the hacker group made like 90
million dollars
why would you ever stop doing this of
course
why would you stop there is absolutely
no incentive not to do this again yeah
you're not going to be friendly
sovereign that's what you need you know
what i would have done you know what i
would have done if i was colonial
pipeline
if i got that thing and it was like yo
we're gonna lock down your pipeline
unless you pass five million dollars you
know what i do i'd be like all right
all right hacker do it play chicken do
it
shut it down get 40 50 million people
ready to hunt you down and take you out
you want to live in luxury you want five
million dollars i'm sure you want to buy
yourself a nice little lambo and
infinity pool how about that
how about instead i send 60 million
people people down on your ass because
you shut down their pipeline
how about we get the federal government
to send some black helicopters
to find out where you're at and shut you
down you want to live wealthy this ain't
the way to do it
bring it on buddy instead they go please
just give us back our pipeline
we'll give you whatever you want because
morally i think that's justified you'd
be the hero in the movie but if you were
the ceo of the company and you
let them shut it down and your company
lost 60 million dollars in revenue as a
result
oh i don't get fired as ceo the next day
i don't care so what
i don't care and then i and then i and
you know i would do when they announced
we are terminating ceo tim paul
immediately i'd say press conference
i do not negotiate with terrorists if
you want to nuke
our cities and shut down our pipelines
we will come for you we will find you
and you will regret it oil companies are
not like
all you know blackwater incapable of
watching their own i'm not saying they
are gonna
right i'm saying when you when you were
shutting down the largest pipeline in
the us was an attack on this country
and instead of the u.s government saying
we are going to hunt you down and make
you regret this choice
we paid them we paid them and then they
they make 90 million dollars
these guys are kicking back pina coladas
in
in antalya somewhere on the beach with a
bunch of other russian tourists
congratulations probably planning the
next one oh yeah with a new name like if
they they're printed the funny money now
they can
they're just giving it away ransomware
probably took him a week to make
you have to act swift and hard against
people like that it is it is
international financial terrorism you
know and even beyond financial terrorism
because you're cutting off people's
access to heat
yes and tim this is what you learned and
what was it i forget that class that you
took um
what's it called where you're going into
like oppositional places
yeah the hostile environment training
they talk about how the u.s
uh americans don't get kidnapped right
because
so this is not negotiate yeah this is
what the so when i went through the
hustle environment training
they did a simulated kidnapping it was
really fun it was it was so much fun
uh it was like role playing uh they
they're they give us this mission
they're like hey you're gonna get in
this van and you're gonna go and do an
interview with this leader of like a
terror organization or whatever
and then the van gets like surrounded
and then you hear like fake guns go off
and then they grab you and they put a
bag over your head and they zip tie it
or something it's like a cloth bag you
can breathe just fine
and then you like that you can't see
where you're going and they bring you
there's like a bunch of weird noises
it's it was so much fun like
i i knew where they were bringing us
because they didn't have like a big
facility
but you can hear like metal clanking and
like muttering and like yelling and then
like guns being messed with
and then they make you stand upright
against the wall for two hours
it was crazy it didn't feel like it felt
like 10 minutes i was just standing
there for two hours
then they bring you in a room and they
put a light right in front of your face
and point it at you and then you can
only see like the waist out of these
guys who are like with an accent asking
you questions
it was a whole lot of fun afterwards
they explained to us like
this was a kidnapping scenario where if
you're a journalist in a hostel
territory this what might happen to you
after they after
everyone got interrogated they make
everyone stand against the wall again
and then also when you hear the door go
boom and then you hear like gunshots
and then you hear like down down down
now now get on the ground
everyone now and we all get on the
ground put your hands on your head now
and then the guys pick us up walk us out
take the bag it was it was so much fun
they told us when you get kidnapped
you got to just try and survive because
the u.s
does not negotiate with terrorists which
means these guys who kidnap you
can only expect a helicopter to fly
overhead dudes jump out and they'll kill
each and every one of you in the
building and your families
so if you kidnap an american you better
apologize and let them go
but germany and spain pay out instantly
so when it comes to people in these
territories in the middle east
they love it when they find someone
speaking german or spanish they're like
free money we're going to make ourselves
4 million bucks
the american guy they're like you better
think twice about this the problem was
isis didn't care they were at war and
they didn't want money they
had ideology so if they found out you're
american they're like good
so depending on you know which country
that's the point
what what we've done now in the us we've
got bad leadership
sorry it's true not like trump was
perfect but they
they they the biggest pipeline in the
country attacked and then darkseid the
company that made the malware was like
we didn't tend to do that
which shows exactly why what i'm saying
works you come out and say
the hacker group darkseid did this find
them
they're responsible could you what do
you think would happen if all the gas
prices skyrocketed
gas shortages sweep across the
southeastern u.s you got 60 million
people
begging joe biden for war yeah
the russian government would be like uh
we're going to lock these guys up i mean
i i get all that but i also just them
like i don't know that it as a company
ceo
as distinct from like a president you
can actually you know make that decision
or that that decision is really yours to
make right like to pay the the
terrorists
to not to not pay them right and then
essentially for 60
million people to go without oil or
something like that who decides to pay
them
you do who decides to not pay them right
but like
i'm saying that you that you are not
like an elected official that
as a moral matter you shouldn't be in
the situation where
you are in a position to get the oil
pipeline running for a reasonable cost
yeah they should have when you're not
and they decide not to do it they should
have been able to go to the government
say it's in your hands we're not paying
i mean that was always their option i
just i think they paid me i can
understand why they paid
you know like the consequences of not i
mean we saw what happened with like the
oil shutdown turned down for a week we
had a massive shortage
yep good people need to start resp like
respecting responsibility
and understanding what it means to be a
part of a country to be a citizen and be
responsible for the
for for for for the people who live here
what's happening now is
someone says for the betterment of
myself
i would rather sacrifice the betterment
of the nation you know it's like
you know ask not what you can do for
your country but what you can do my word
you have gotten right wing in the last
year or two my friend
that's not right at all that's left wing
to be responsible
no not i mean collectivism is not right
wing no but like this
i mean there's there there's some big
time like sacrifice for the greater good
and not just for like
you know soft great or good but do we
have a responsibility
do we have a responsibility to protect
the people of this country
yes absolutely so if we know that paying
a ransom to terrorists will make this
country worse and cause more suffering
should we stand together and say we we
will not negotiate with terrorists i
mean i think
i think that there's actually a good
case for a law to be
written that basically bans companies
from paying the sort of thing and then
you know criminalizes it prevent
essentially
basically making it so that the
companies the incentives are different
and and doing something similar so this
was the easy way out
that sacrifices our long-term prospects
for this country
now we're already hearing that even
before this this was before the colonial
pipeline cna paid 40 million
that probably paved the way for more of
this and it'll keep
happening they're going to hit cities
and what's going to happen is
ideological extremists
they're not interested in the money
they're going to start asking for
exorbitant fees like 40 million
knowing i don't care if they pay or not
if they pay great love more money to do
more of this when they gave the hackers
five million dollars they funded a
terrorist operation
that's true there's another angle to
this uh i don't know if we've talked
about it which is the crypto ankle
right i read a pretty compelling article
today that was like point making one of
the points that
you know one of the current primary use
cases of crypto
is ransom right they used uh i believe
they used bitcoin to pay the the
the ransom it may have been monero or
something and i mean it'd be very
challenging to do that in dollars or any
actual currency through
through the banking system because there
would be so many safeguards you know
imposed by government
um and there's none of those imposed on
crypto and
you know one has to like unless unless
they use something like monero it's all
trackable
and so they have to use i guess my point
you know i know you're a crypto guy
tim but like the logic that you just
espoused about like the need to
sacrifice for the greater good and the
in the good of the country like i feel
like there's there's a pretty compelling
argument that the greater good
um in the context of avoiding ransom and
and
really straight also the strength of the
dollar as a country would suggest that
maybe like we should have a negative
attitude towards cryptocurrency
just because bad people bad people use
dollars all the time
sure bad people use dollars all the time
but that doesn't mean that it's a lot
harder
people use the internet all the time
should we get rid of the internet it
allows bad people to communicate
no encrypted encrypted chat allows
journalists to communicate we should get
rid of that huh no no
no no no just because there's one
negative use case we can't throw the
whole thing out we have to recognize
that
it's a tool right but i mean if if
there's a you know if cryptos
like there aren't that huge number of
use cases for crypto as compared to
other things i mean it's a
you know it's a currency right it's
supposed to function the story i
wouldn't call bitcoin necessarily a
currency a lot of people want it to be
but
right it's hard it's not extremely easy
the transaction takes a decent amount of
time it costs money
so it is a is it's a digital
non-copyable asset
sure and so i mean they're like you know
the other things you talk about they're
like obvious
massive huge external uses if if a
primary use case
so smart contracts for crypto right look
look look the the long story long story
i don't think you know enough about
crypto to make that argument maybe not
bitcoin enables things called smart
contracts
the technology is in its infancy
ethereum really expanded upon it
and so bad people use technology for bad
things tnt wasn't invented to kill
people but
they called nobel the merchant because
they know a decent amount about smart
contracts right like they're like
self-executing contracts
right right it can it can really become
an efficient way of
processing tons of things in fact smart
contracts can be used
blockchains one of the one of the most
interesting things i've heard is how it
can be used for
automatic self-driving cars to
communicate with each other and keep
ledgers of all of the interactions
very easily so okay there's there's
there's a lot that we don't want a lot
of ways
it's like saying it's like saying at the
beginning of the internet it's like
you know 1997's like i don't know
criminals are using this stuff so we
should we should we should
not be fans of it if you implanted it
into you you could have it
your body when your body gets hungry
your coffee machine turns on and gets
your coffee brewing for you
and gets the the microwave coming out
that's out there but it's common
the point is i think you can separate
like the technology of i mean
the cryptocurrency can be replicated
obviously there are a million different
coins out there right
and the the use cases that are
technological right smart contracts
uh whatever this you know drive
self-driving cars thing
blockchain technology right don't rely
on the cryptocurrency itself being worth
tens of thousands of dollars per coin
right they would function they would
function with it being worth up you know
point zero zero one and dogecoin is
right and yeah sure and i mean if you
were actually trying to develop this
technology you wouldn't be like well
we're gonna rely on bitcoin for our
self-driving car exchanges because why
would you
incur the expense of using bitcoin i
think you know the
the the primary you know i guess you
know the way i see it from the persp
like a regulatory perspective is it's
like is it in the interests of
um you know like the united states
as a as a whole as a country for
cryptocurrency to be this
for the people yeah this store of value
and
and and therefore like it and being used
as this
very you know opaque currency um outside
of the
you know the banking system i don't know
the answer is undoubtedly
yes when you have corrupt politicians
exploiting the people
the point is the people are supposed to
be the government we the people
the consent of the government instead we
have elites who are extracting value and
burning everything to the ground
and they're using nancy pelosi buying
tons of stock
you know or or who are these other uh
republicans who had a bunch of
perfect trades
they make a bunch of money we see it
over and over again that these people in
congress will make like the perfect
trade just before some bill gets passed
that causes a boom or
collapse so you've got elitists who are
extracting from the system
you've got the banking system the mass
printing of money joe biden now wants to
spend 1.9 trillion
at a time uh not 1.9 trillion dollars at
a time
when we're having labor shortages
because nobody wants to work so yes
to secure the value of the labor of the
individuals in this country
bitcoin is fantastic it's a lot it right
now
bitcoin functions primarily as a not
a non-copyable digital asset for a lot
of people and a lot of people aren't
even
in bitcoin a lot of financial
institutions are getting involved in it
but it's decentralized
it's got stakes in a bunch of different
places with a bunch of different people
and it's a good thing
when i'm talking about the pipeline i'm
talking about the people
standing up together and refusing to let
terrorists
take advantage of us because again the
most important point here
not only are we encouraging the terror
like it's going to keep happening
we are funding it when we pay the ransom
so i mean
the people like again i mean we're
talking about a private company ceo with
shareholders who has an obligation to
to maximize shareholder value right it's
like to the extent that this would be
imposed
so that the ceo i mean i you i mean i
think you would need some sort of
policy or like new law to constrain the
behavior of ceos so that
they don't do the thing that is in their
shareholders best interest i.e
pay a small you know a relatively small
ransom to get the pipeline back on right
it's certainly
if you know the ransom people got paid 5
million it definitely was costing more
than 5 million for the pipeline to be
shut off to colonial
should we allow people to give money to
isis if isis is threatening someone in
their family
no no should we allow companies to fund
directly pay
millions of dollars to terrorist
organizations agreed and so
and but this is my this is the corollary
right like we're talking about a gu then
we're talking about a government policy
that says okay for the collective good
we're going to ban
these ransoms we're going to criminalize
it i actually think that's a that is
reasonably sound
um because right like that's a way to
solve the sort of
you know the principal agent problem
right like or it's i guess it's a
collective action problem
everybody's better off if nobody pays
ransom but it's in the individual
interest to pay ransom
right so you you know that's how a
government policy can come around well
there's there's another dynamic to it
which is again if
if you know there's an individual
incentive for you know various
individuals to have crypto but the net
effect of having crypto maybe is
negative because it facilitates ransom
like maybe the government should have a
policy that is you know adversarial
towards crypto
that that there's no there's no
connection here it makes no sense well i
mean like without crypto it's pretty
hard to see how it's about the internet
it's really hard to see how
the terrorists get paid sure but i mean
the internet has you know the infinite
uses that we all use it for today chris
not in 1995.
i mean 1995. there were news reports
saying the internet wouldn't last and it
didn't do anything and and here's the
other point like adversarial thought
script doesn't necessarily mean
adversarial towards the technological
applications of crypto that you're
discussing
adversary we got section 230 from
congress in the mid-90s to protect
the internet in its infancy to embolden
it and empower it
right so if anything we need the
government to help us make it better and
strengthen it
maybe that's a better way of dealing
with these things but i mean
i mean what do you think about a
national cryptocurrency like one
you know different distinct from bitcoin
founder you know supported by the
government
yeah you see that they're already i
think india is doing it i think the us
is already working on central bank
people are calling it fed coin yeah i
mean
there's other problems obviously that
come to that because you you know
whenever you have a currency you think
the federal reserve is a good thing
i mean i think here's the the thing i
think in general one really good way to
have an economic crisis is to have a
currency that you cannot
uh dilute um the that's the lesson
you know the way to think about it is i
mean that's the lesson of the euro
crisis
so this is this is actually like an
economic question about the inability
for
like what happens when you know
countries become
less productive um and there's there's a
basic behavioral treat people don't like
wage cuts no one likes seeing their pay
take home pay cut
in in nominal terms um
and so basically you know in america
like when that happens or in when you
have floating exchange rates well then
the exchange rate just floats and your
goods don't purchase as much of german
goods
but at least in your own country wages
don't go down but they're all in the
euro
and as a result like wages you know
we're sticky downwards it's hard for
them to go down so instead
a lot of people just don't get employed
and that's the euro crisis that's the
gold standard of the 1920s in england
um there's a lot of there's a lot of
good reasons to think that like
a really obvious trigger of recessions
in the past has been
um fixed exchange rates and so it's not
obvious to me that
you would want to have a you know the
government unable to dilute a money
supply
because in that world essentially you're
dealing with a fixed currency and if you
have a
decrease in overall economic
productivity that's going to manifest
itself in unemployment if you don't have
dilution
i like being able to spin up new cryptos
to avoid
the inability to dilute so it would be a
sort of dilution by creating new finite
supplies yeah i mean i think you know i
think that crypto as technology
i i don't think relies on having crypto
as the store of value
you know un you know anonymous world
currency
right um and that you know i think the
real query is
if the if you know the primary use case
of the anonymous world currency
you know crypto is ranked that's not
anonymous
okay well i guess not anonymous but like
pseudonymous or essentially like hard to
it's actually the opposite it's uh
bitcoin tracks everything you do
right and they know who has what like so
there's stories all the time about which
white supremacist has which bitcoin and
how much sure
so it's actually more transparent and
bad for a lot of these groups trying to
operate for better or worse in the
shadows
there is monero which does obfuscate
transactions
right and and you know i mean obviously
these i mean
every one of these ransomwares we're
seeing is being paid off in crypto right
yeah i don't know
is it so they use like uh pools to
manipulate the flow
and then like take them in and launder a
bitcoin and make it harder to track
right and so i mean there's but they and
they they do that and they don't do it
through the normal banking system right
there's nobody getting a wire transfer
of ransomware money
right that would be insane and no
probably yeah
well i mean wouldn't i mean to to a bank
account i mean if you a bank account
could be supervised by the sovereigns
and
sure but much more easily than crypto
i'm not denying that it's a lot easier
to pay a ransom with crypto there was a
bank with a bank account but i'm sure
people have found ways to pay ransoms
through bank accounts because crypto is
relatively new
sure but it's like the you know the
explosion of these these ransomware
attacks they're probably just like what
it
is
what do they do in the movies like swiss
bank accounts where the swiss yeah but i
mean those
don't those still don't work as well
right they're still sovereign all right
new technology
you know so so i think what we what we
should be saying is
we'd be having the exact same
conversation in the 90s about the
internet
it's it's it's kind of an absurd
argument i mean i don't know i think
you know the the internet again we you
know the internet argument
suggests that i mean there's there's
this plethora of use cases for the
internet i mean we use it for
everything we do now everything right in
the 90s we didn't
and so people could say why should we
have this thing that's like 1.01 percent
of our economy
be facilitating crime sure but i mean i
guess i've i think i've answered that by
saying that
the technological use cases of crypto
that are
you know the things that some of the
again you gave the example of cars and
smart contracts sure but they're not
reliant on
crypto itself being a store of value and
an anonymous global currency
well it is like there are tokens that
are utility tokens that are seemingly
shouldn't be held as value but they have
value because they're
they're non-copyable assets there's
their their their scarcity to them
like dogecoin has value in in its memory
and the
con the confidence people have in the
idea of doge being funny
so they buy it even though it's an
inflationary coin and they keep printing
more sure so maybe i mean you know
there's
my understanding of bitcoin technology
is that there's more and more coins i
mean
at an ever decreasing rate but more and
more coins mined
via a computer mm-hmm but it's going to
be about 20 million total
right so i mean imagine if you're
totally focused solely on the
technological use of crypto you'd
probably want
something that has a dramatically higher
inflation rate right like a dogecoin
yeah i guess or something that creates
you know you know it's so trivially easy
to mine
more new coins as opposed to difficult
because like the additional bitcoin is
the yeah i guess i don't know
yeah um but like that would
be better technologically and then also
that would be a terrible
you know that would not be a great use
case for
i don't think for like ransomware if
like the currency is just like
constantly being eroded then
nobody would be really willing to pay
very much for any particular crypto
right but that like a good portion of
crypto is inflationary in a good portion
is deflation area right it's just
crypto is just non-copyable digital
assets and there's a lot of things that
can be done with them
sure and i and i i get all that and so
you know the question i mean again i'm
you know i'm not saying all crypto bad
i'm saying crypto designed to be a store
of value
global stable global currency probably
bad but it's not
but it i mean like if you look at if you
look at the original ideas of what
bitcoin was
a lot of people would argue that it was
meant to be a currency where it's at
today it certainly isn't
right i know and but perhaps we
shouldn't be trying
to do that that particular use case it
could be like you could use apples
as or you could use seashells as a
currency maple syrup too yeah some
anything they used to use seashells
gold they had to figure out gold coins
because they were soft and you could cut
them thin enough
and then they had made now they make
cotton these dollars are made of cotton
yeah um but the thing about crypto is
you could make a token like
canon who we use canon cameras could
make a crypto
that's like a smart contract crypto that
you know if you have it then when you
sit down all your cameras turn on
and so but if you don't have it you got
to do it all manually so it's a it's a
smart contract that does this stuff so
you want to go buy it
doesn't have any value fiscally but it
has value
functionally so it will have fiscal
value as a result
and it's like there's no avoiding it the
mind means their mind utility token
yeah isn't it isn't supposed to have an
inherent value necessarily
right it's used for but because it you
can use a mines token to boost your post
well views have value and the token can
do that then the token has monetary
value
sure um i mean i can see i
like my point is not necessarily to say
that like the tokens everything's going
to
happen
yeah exactly like zero monetary value
but rather that
um making them undesirable as stores of
value
right it might be good because if you do
so i mean i don't know again this is
beyond my technical capability i don't
like the idea of the government printing
money to steal the value of
working-class people to give to the
ultra wealthy i mean
so i like crypto for that reason i don't
know i mean that's that's that's the
underlying argument for like the gold
standard
and general like fixed exchange rates in
general and i mean i think that the
difference is bitcoin can be forked and
modified
based on consensus within the
decentralized network so
when you look at biden saying he wants
to print 6 trillion or
borrow up to like 30 trillion or
whatever and they keep giving money to
people who aren't working
and then those people who aren't working
are then buying from people who are
working
it's essentially register redistributing
wealth and giving people a benefit to
not work while others have to work
because
certainly someone has to that's only
possible because they can just make more
over
nonstop and inflation is essentially a
hidden tax on
savings agreed bitcoin is the opposite
but there's not it's not just
bitcoin there's a bunch of other
cryptocurrencies that do a bunch of
other things
so many of them have value because
people value them like anything
and so i don't like the idea that
working-class people can't save money
they they gotta spend money to be in the
bank
if they hold the dollars and the dollars
lose value maybe they can't afford a
full ounce of gold they'll try and buy
something
i like the idea that they have a hedge
and bitcoin makes it extremely easy for
for most people
i don't know i mean i think i think it's
extraordinarily risky as a hedge
uh and i think in general if you're
trying to hedge against inflation
for one of the better ways to do it and
if we're also one of the socially better
ways to do it is to invest in stocks
um equities what makes you think
bitcoin's risky
what makes me think bitcoin's risky um
because i could like does it produce
itself growth right does it produce
profit yes
it produces heat when it's created right
it consumes well the computer produces
the produces
the computer but i guess it doesn't
actually just trans transfers the heat
right transmutes it i guess so it
transmutes but i mean it
electronics energy yeah consumes
electricity consumes electricity
like it doesn't like businesses you know
transform lesser value you know factors
of production into
finished products that are more valuable
so like a digital asset that can't be
copied is valuable to people
right i'm saying but like the asset
itself versus the company that makes it
right like if you're investing in a
company that transforms something into
you know something of lesser value
something more value just that's
literally what they're doing though
but like again commodity versus the
company right like when i'm talking
about
why like investigating equities grow
they produce
you know companies produce things and
transform you know if they don't make
things more valuable they go out of
business
is a large rock worth less than the iron
that is perfectly extracted into an
ingot from the rock
like obviously the ingots worth more as
a piece of metal refined
so taking energy and converting that
into a non-copyable digital asset
that someone can hold and can be used
for smart contracts if people want to do
it
sure it becomes something more valuable
sure right okay so that and then
there's again distinguish the business
and the commodity right like the
business of
you know making bitcoin versus and you
can invest in the companies that mine
for sure right
right and so but like again my point is
that
as a hedge against inflation right the
token itself like there could be
a move against it and it could go
dramatically
i don't know like i see you know bitcoin
as being in some ways worse than gold
um or more risky than gold because it
could go to zero in a way how could it
go to zero
you know in the same way that gold kind
of zero
gold gold has just underlying
fundamental use cases like
beauty you can uh industrial you can
definitely eat it
colloidal flakes i used to drink it a
lot at the hot tub but
with with with crypto again you have
smart contracts you have underlying use
cases you have a lot of things
right but they don't really mean like
they don't rely on any particular crypto
using gold as a conductor doesn't rely
on the value in fact it's inhibited
we could be using gold for technology
but the cost is prohibitively expensive
because people just want it for no
reason
right i mean people want gold and i mean
you could argue that that underlying
you know that creates some higher demand
for but like those
bitcoin sure okay but the point
the idea is not like bitcoin like crypto
right if you say crypto has use cases
therefore bitcoin can't go to zero
it's like well bitcoin has use cases so
it's extremely unlikely to go to zero
i mean but like every those use cases
are universal to cryptos generally and
so can be replaced by other cryptos
right not necessarily i mean
theoretically you could create
an identical coin to bitcoin just using
its open source code
but you don't have the network you know
i mean
that the net is that even an advantage
because of how much energy the network
is burning it's
it's an advantage because people use it
it's universally like what if
someone said like gold i could use
aluminum
you know like it was wasn't aluminum
worth more than gold at one point
because it was harder to pressure
yeah so just use a different look if
metal is valuable then we'll use any
metal we want
gold could go to zero because aluminum
could go up or we could find a giant
asteroid of
gold and we're like wow it's worth a
thousandth of what we thought hey
whatever right
that's true i mean you can't do that
with bitcoin diamonds are intentionally
inflated in value they're really not
worth that
we can mass produce diamonds
artificially using those those neon gas
chambers
so gold has some use cases in terms of
a conductive metal i think silver is
better and people don't use it for the
most part because gold is way too
expensive to actually use so people just
like having it as a status symbol
it's kind of a meaningless value but the
reality is gold is scarce
and so people value it as a hedge
because it's a scarce
commodity honestly like i'm not like pro
gold
um i'm pro investing in companies and
and like the american economy
so you think being invested in a in a
valuable company that can weather the
storm of a depression is about right
it's people are going to keep wanting
iphones because
they make a incredible product um that
you know or you know companies that have
like a sort of durable moat
a competitive mode um they're going to
be able they have
pricing power so if inflation increases
the cost of their factors of production
they can increase the price of the goods
and people will still buy them
um and that ability to durably make
profit
uh you know is means that they are a
good even in a world of inflation means
they are a good hedge against inflation
that's like one thing i mean you know
you can
like gold is more of a it's more
speculating on fear
in a way right like you're you know gold
isn't going to somehow
magically replace the dollar as currency
but rather
if you're buying gold you're sort of
betting a good way to think about buying
gold that you're betting people are
going to be more scared in a year or two
years than they are currently and
therefore it'll go up in price you're
also betting the system
will stay intact the same is true to a
certain degree with crypto but more sure
but you're much more wisely invested in
that case because you've invested
massively in ammunition and guns and
things like that yeah it'll be much more
valuable which is why
i i buy decent i have gold and i have
silver
right but i think about it's not so much
about the guns it's about investing in
function so we've also got we've got a
kiln
we've got a forge we've got
and for the most part it's fun things to
you can make we've also got 3d printers
this is mostly for making stuff but i'd
rather buy something that does a thing
than just buy a rock yeah agreed i don't
i don't think much of it but i still do
buy the shiny rocks to be honest
yeah gold they used to wear gold crowns
you know the kings i think
it has healing properties apparently it
was in the earth and
you know you get your trace minerals
when you eat vegetables you get like a
little bit of iron in your diet
you used to get a little bit of gold in
your diet gold gold was just scarce and
easy to mold
they they mined most of us out of the
earth because they wanted it for
currency and now when you eat you don't
get the trace mineral anymore the gold's
missing so
people will supplement it by eating
colloidal they'll suspend it in water
and drink a little bit at a time is that
way all the flakes are in the little
sushi like they're really nice
restaurants because it actually has it
has value i hear that it cold flakes on
a tiramisu
the neurons in your brain it'll coat
them and allow them to conduct
electricity faster i felt that when i'm
stretching when my muscle would rip
if i had eaten gold it will fill in the
muscle and i can keep stretching
i don't know about all that it would
like soak into their skin the the kings
and that's why they would have
silver and gold rings people turned blue
silver's anti-bacterial so if you have
an infection silver can cure help you
cure that or heal that
and then you turn blue a lot of these
metals palladium and platinum it's just
not a real
it's not a science people haven't really
scientifically done much
i don't think with that that research
but trace minerals are legit for your
diet
true cryptocurrency is a great
technology moses they say ground up that
golden cash and
fed into the people hitting anybody for
making a good trade like if you made a
good trade you made a good trade
like that's that the rules of trading
are you make money with i think there
are people who just
like are bitcoin doomers
arbitrarily like dogecoin i understand
if you're like dogecoin's a bad bet
because it's an inflationary currency
that's just mass-produced
right so it's like guaranteed to go down
unless people are memeing it
up which can't go like really can't go
that long
now elon musk is trying to get
developers to
alter doge because they can they
basically can because it's effectively
abandonware
and then maybe they'll do something to
make it more stable but it's an
incredibly
unstable coin incredibly yeah you know i
mean
and elon of course encouraged everybody
to buy it because elon is a stock
promoter
with some research projects on the side
yeah right like that's it so he probably
i bet he sold all of those
at the top oh sure right right you know
what do they say uh
buy on the rumor sell on the news is
that the saying right i mean there's a
weird
way of making money in crypto that just
becomes obvious right if you're a
massive social media influencer
you just buy a bunch of a random no no
no no no no you can make it
like that yeah you can make erc20 tokens
just instantly
yeah make tokens encourage your your
followers to buy them
sell the tokens crazy it's crazy
i can make a bunch of t-shirts and sell
them isn't that crazy
i can i can make a t-shirt and be like
everybody should buy this t-shirt
and get your to the moon t-shirt at
timcast.com by clicking the store button
i can make t-shirts and sell them i mean
the
the question is going to be whether it
falls under the technical definition of
a security
it's not it's a commodity i don't know i
don't know if the sec has said that
so the issue is if uh what's happened a
lot of these companies
that the sec has gone after or
questioned is that they'll start a
company
create the tokens and then sell them to
get funding for the company
and so they say you're issuing a
security it's a really interesting
argument because i can make little cards
that say
like i can make i can buy a bunch of
white cardstock and autograph them and i
can get a million of them
and i can say who wants to buy them and
people will buy them
for a dollar each and then i make a
million dollars if you've got if you got
the network and the influence
is that a security no you're not getting
anything from the company
i don't know i'm you know this is an
area of law i actually you know it was i
took securities regulation in 3l when
you stopped paying attention because
your your job's already settled at that
point so you know
my my knowledge of securities
regulations are fairly weak
theoretically making a million tokens is
just
a digital object and you can make it and
you can sell it
it's a matter of like what they call ico
initial coin offering that's when they
spin up a million and then they'd sell
500 000 of them the issue is if the
coins have a function for the business i
suppose right if they're utilities then
they're not securities this is my
rudimentary understanding i don't know
if
it's real or not man as a lawyer i have
no idea okay maybe we're
we're in too deep you guys but okay so
my thoughts on crypto
i don't like the government spying on us
i don't like it knowing or or people
with guns knowing every move that i'm
making
but i also i i so in that sense
i support monero but i see the danger
and
of of not being able to keep an eye on
dangerous activity
but i also value i want everyone to have
their own crypto that you can
you can use my crypto to buy my services
with a discount so they'll create
inherent value
you know my behavior creates inherent
value for my crypto and then we have an
unlimited
supply but it's also limited because you
know how many there will ever be
i don't know i i you know i used to
because the reason i argue so much about
this is because i used to be a hardcore
libertarian like i bought gold i was
into the you know
in 2008 or something i made money on the
trade even though i was wrong about
the reason why it went up um and and so
you know i look back and i'm not even
sure
you know and i think a lot about i've
thought a lot about currency generally
not necessarily crypto
itself but currency more broadly and you
know there's real benefits to having
a reserve currency as a country and
being the beneficiaries of this right
like
the way to think about it is china
basically is subsidizing
so much of what we do and you know as is
the rest of the world the fact that we
can just print immense amounts of money
and i mean we're going to see some
inflation but not like
have the currency collapse into a heap
um and why doesn't it do that well it's
needed to pay tribute
to them you know by 300 million of the
wealthiest people in the world
to pay tribute to the most powerful
institution in the world um
and so my opinion i think bitcoin will
go to a million bucks
i think you know max kaiser has said he
his target for this year is like 220
000.
if i had listened to max kaiser in 2012
i'd be a billionaire right now
i'm not exaggerating i'm literally not
exaggerating i mean i like
billionaires i mean bitcoin was trading
at less than a dollar
yeah i remember i remember that i
remember seeing you could have spent
bitcoin
you there was a period where uh 2011 you
could have spent 10 grand
and it would have made you a billionaire
in 10 years that's crazy i asked to do
like where do i get it it was 2011 i
think and
we were playing poker and he's like you
got to write down your key on a piece of
paper i was like what
i remember or i lose it he's like then
you lose all your
bitcoins they're worth 70 cents dude i'm
not messing with it it was it was
it was it was so difficult to buy that
was one of the issues too back in 2011
my famous
famous story when my friend talked me
out of buying he did but it was also
just like the
it was easy to talk me out of it because
i didn't even know how to buy it i'm on
these forums and they're like willing to
sell bitcoin and i'm like bro you're in
nebraska i'm in l.a
like i don't even i don't even know so i
was like whatever there's a thing called
the bitcoin faucet that was giving out i
think .05 of a bitcoin every 15 minutes
and so i was just like hitting the
button and i had like 1.5 bitcoin just
from this thing
and it was worth less than a dollar and
i was like whatever yeah
i mean at the time everybody thought
they had better ways to do this
now that would be 60 grand you know and
i mean like and that's where i mean on
the other hand
i'm not you know i'll candidly admit
like i got
that trade wrong that would have been
great to get in on the early bitcoin
trade
as a speculative matter see here's what
you don't understand i've been through
that loop
probably 10 times when i saw it at 70
cents
and then it hit a dollar i was like a
dollar
man i should have bought then i saw it
five dollars and i was like oh
then i saw it hit 15. oh then 20 then 50
then 100 then 200 then 500 than a
thousand
and every single time i said if only i
bought then if only i bought
then and i remember when it hit 1700 i
was like you know what
it was an all-time high i was like i'm
buying it because i know it's going to
happen
it's going to go up and say if only i
bought again and i bought it i bought a
small amount
and then i forgot about it and then i
just went out with my daily business
and then i remember when it hit because
it was it i bought at 1700
it went up to like 13 in november i
bought a little bit more i was like oh
well you know you look so i got a little
bit in my in my wallet whatever i
ignored it
then when it hit 40 within like three
months i was like
where's that phone and i'm like looking
for the account and then i found it and
i was like i'm sure glad i bought
peter schiff has been anti-bitcoin
forever
yeah he's also been pro gold and he's
been wrong about a lot of things but
it's funny
that it's like bitcoin hits you know 100
bucks and he's like ah this is nothing
and now he's still complaining about it
because it fell 30
to 40 000 and he's like you see the
thing about bitcoin i'm like bro i'm
sorry dude
you want to complain about bitcoin it's
at 40 grand
do you think i'm upset that it fell to
40 grand do you think
most of the people have been active in
the crypto space are crying right now
there's a dude who like sold his house
to buy a bunch of bitcoin and that this
was four or four years ago bitcoin was
at 1700
and he's still actively like woo this is
great
because it is a new technology and
imagine if you bought apple stock
you know before the ipod came out you
would be
very happy after the ipod it's it's it's
not the same thing
i totally get your point i like
investing in functional things like
companies it makes a lot of sense
you're hoping the company continues to
be functional right like there's always
the risk that the company stops making
something people want
you know or or just has some some
business problems so it's a different
kind of investment
it is it is a different kind of
investment bitcoin is first in
and best dressed it is decentralized
and extremely difficult if not
impossible to
control the network now elon of course
can screw with it
but a lot of people think he's the one
who caused this massive sell-off it's
actually tax
season and he probably knew that which
is why he made his move
i don't know why he made his move but
you see people throughout the year
especially when bitcoin went from
thirteen
to sixty four thousand dollars probably
cashed out a little bit and went partied
tax season comes up you gotta pay the
irs when they're like hey where'd you
get that 15 grand from
i cash out some bitcoin okay well you
got to pay 30 oh let me sell some
bitcoin to pay you off
that caused a huge self and here's what
happened bitcoin dropped down to i think
29.8 and then almost in a split second
jumped
right back up to 35 why because there
was a whale
waiting with a program preset the moment
bitcoin is 30
you put in millions of dollars someone
noticed 750 million dollars move off of
exchanges around this time
somebody became a multi-billionaire in
that sell-off
sure i mean you know that's you know but
i mean i guess like that sort of trading
logic applies to every any sort of
security absolutely ever right yeah and
so
i mean the question is this is this like
a really going to be valuable thing or
is this going to be tulips
right i think we're we're at 10 years
yeah it's been around for i think 13
years bitcoin 2008.
and so it's continually climbed it's
been adopted by some of the wealthiest
financial institutions on the planet
you know one of the things that really
got me is i i when i was at 70 cents i'm
like nobody uses this why am i going to
be confident something nobody uses
then when i got to 20 bucks you had an
old magic the gathering website mount
gox it was mtgox why
it was magic the gathering online
exchange and then when this guy was like
bitcoin's a thing he started calling it
mount gox like it's actually a mountain
it's like
rebranding to sell bitcoin well that
that went belly up i lost bitcoin there
they got hacked
right yeah btc or i don't know what
happened but btce goes belly up i lost
some bitcoin there but they still
i didn't care they weren't worth that
much and it wasn't heavily adopted
then the winklevoss twins were like
we're gonna put in what are they putting
like hundreds of millions of dollars
then you see a bunch of financial
institutions finally say we're going to
start off
offering these portfolios i was like
okay i really don't think
these financial institutions will let
themselves lose the money so they'll
resist
they'll probably manipulate like elon
musk does
so that's why a lot of people buy
dogecoin a lot of dumb people sold
i'm not telling anybody what to do no
financial advice here but elon
is pumping doge he wants to get rich off
of pumping doge in my opinion
and so these these whales these high
profile individuals and 55 million
followers are going to be manipulating
playing that game
sure but i mean you know i think housing
crisis right like the
nobody thought the housing market would
go down nobody thought that the banks
would get
you know lose any money to the housing
crisis and surely nobody thought layman
brothers would go under you know i don't
know
i'm i'm for sure bitcoin bitcoin could
could end tomorrow i suppose
i just uh the bigger risk i suppose is
that it's young
people have confidence in gold because
they've been born into confidence in
gold
i mean i think it's silly to have
confidence in gold frankly too you know
like
i mean i want to be clear i think that
it's just it's a thing and bitcoin won't
end
um looking at it as a is a monetary
value is wrong it's not wrong it's
it's just it's it's one percent of the
way there is short-sighted
it's the functionality of the of the
technology that's
ins it's it's changing everything about
the way we interact as humans
and it will continue to do so as we
become more cybernetic
you know more attached to these devices
i can trade and
make millions of dollars in a split
second now so put it simply
there this was something that this could
maybe a meme but people are pointing out
the cost
the energy costs for the financial
system that exists today
is like 40 percent more than the energy
cost of maintaining
bitcoin just bitcoin right but i mean it
just strikes me as
you know couldn't you out compete
bitcoin with one that was less energy
yeah absolutely right yeah you know just
like silver's a better conductor than
gold and we can use silver for certain
things but we typically hold them as
stores of value
there's going to be more
cryptocurrencies there was a super chat
we'll read more but someone mentioned
that dogecoin
is actually stable because it has a
standard two percent inflation per year
i don't know if that's true but people
are saying that basically means
yeah i i slowly go up i have no you know
i have no idea
like i don't invest in crypto and no
financial advice
right i'm excited for i mean i wouldn't
call myself a doomer but i'm a skeptic
certainly i like would you guys like
inject a cryptocurrency into you to
control machines
there's a patent for uh i think there's
a patent for like monitoring
your body levels or something it's a
microsoft patent zero six zero six zero
six something like that yeah you either
eat it or you inject it you put a tattoo
on and it can measure
if you're looking at a commercial it can
tell that you're seeing that commercial
and then it'll pay you crypto for
watching it creepy
dude and you're going to be able to turn
your machines on from a distance like
with
would you do it because you're going to
be trapped you're going to be able to
turn your electricity on your home
the moment you walk in your home without
having to call a company as you wake up
you don't i'll start for you you're not
going to need to send in your
identification or anything you're going
to literally walk in
and you're going to scan it's going to
get your address and it's going to know
you'll be able to walk into your
friend's house and power their stuff
while you're there like contribute to
their network
sure but like you can kind of already do
some of that right i don't know like i
just got a new apartment and there's
like
literally i can control and i create my
whole apartment for my phone i can venmo
my friend right exactly right
basically like the rudimentary
beginnings of contributing
you know sure right right the the issue
is it's decentralized
decentralization is epic we need more of
it
i mean i i don't know i think there's
positives and negatives all right well
let's jump to a new story
politifact has archived a fact check
they have
rebunked the lab leak hypothesis
archived fact checked tucker carlson
guest heirs debunked conspiracy theory
that coveted 19 was created in a lab
interesting they have an editor's note
from may 17 2021
the great rebunking they say when this
fact check was first published in
september 2020
politifact sources included researchers
who asserted the tsar's co
covid ii virus could not have been
manipulated
that assertion is now more widely
disputed for that reason
we are removing this fact check from our
database pending a more
thorough review currently we consider
the claim to be unsupported by evidence
and in dispute
the original fact check in its entirety
is preserved below for transparency and
archival purposes
read our may 2021 report for more
information blah blah blah blah blah
what they're basically saying is they
published fake news based on some guy's
opinion
let me stress they say researchers who
asserted
politifact can we change your name to
pull it opinion
because having some guys come on and say
here's what i think
is not fact checking it's opinion
checking
i could pull the opinion out of the ass
of some homeless guy in my alley who
says that he thinks it's not true and i
can publish to my website how about i do
that
i don't know who these researchers are
this is what annoys me about the
mainstream media
our opinion guys are facts your opinion
guys
are wrong that's the name of the game
yeah i mean if you don't have total
content for the new york times the
washington post yet i don't
know what it would take one of the weird
things about facts is they can be wrong
like a fact can be not right but it's
still
like if you say the sky is red that is a
fact
that is a factual statement it's not
correct you're
also wrong but it is still it's not an
opinion it's a statement of fact that is
not right that's that's actually that
it's actually a good point
and i think you understand this you have
to make a statement to fact
in order to be sued for defamation it's
a false statement of fact
right but it has to be legally
considered a statement there's a factual
statement in this context though right
like so this is clearly susceptible to
fact-checking right like did the
did the virus come from a lab or not the
real i think the real
question is would it be a conspiracy
theory and i would argue that it
couldn't be a conspiracy theory because
there's no conspiracy
theorized right well not just that it's
when this story came out it was a is it
possible it no one said
it is well a lot of people said it was
but like in in media in conservative
media in independent media
they were saying interesting interesting
and the reason for it like right when
this story broke i even talked about it
before there was anything happening in
the u.s
because the wuhan institute was right
next to the wet market right
and so everybody was like yo and you
don't you don't have to say you don't
have to think there's like some
colluding
chinese scientists deciding to you know
evil
and unleash this virus on everybody you
could be like somebody made a mistake
that's not a conspiracy theory right you
know if one person
could have done something it's not a
conspiracy right i always said that it's
about that i think i told you this joke
or
before like people would say the notre
dame the idea that notre dame burned
because of arson oh that's a conspiracy
theory
no one person can burn down a building
or not a conspiracy or it could have
been a dude smoking or flicked a
cigarette
right exactly it could have been an
accident could have been intentional
whatever
right so this is the problem with
today's media is that if it doesn't fit
the narrative
and they want power they will
immediately assert opinion as fact and
get away with it
it's also they they almost they see
their jobs totally wrong like this whole
you know since it's literally just since
trump since trump they've seen their
jobs no longer as like
discovering truth but rather policing
heresy
right so here's a here's a weird fact
did you know that like at the turn of
the century
there wha imagine okay here's the here's
the question really frame it
what do you think the most popular major
was at the turn of the 20th century the
most popular what
major in college what do you think
people graduated folklore and mythology
close enough theology wow
[Laughter]
there's always going to be a market for
mediocre intellects who can do nothing
but point and say something doesn't fit
conventional wisdom
right so we have to do something with
those people and in the turn of the
century the
you know the con received wisdom meant
that they would all be theology majors
policing heresy
now they're all journalists policing
conspiracy theories
everything's a conspiracy even when one
person does it because conspiracy theory
just means
story we don't agree with correct but
but i i have to stress politifact
did no research on this none whatsoever
they get an opinion
and someone guy goes in my opinion i
think it's not true debunked
we have officially debunked a conspiracy
theory by getting a guy with an opinion
to say it wasn't true
all right well well there are scientists
who have tons of opinions on like string
theory or m theory or whatever
and they probably don't agree with each
other on the math which one's the
conspiracy whichever one the
corporations dictate
so here i got a bunch of sources for you
check it out
you may have heard that uh rand paul
questioned fauci about gain of function
research
newsweek reported on this we've talked
about it with luke when he was here
gain of function research i think luke
took a more um
apocalyptic view of it where it was like
to make you know luke was saying to make
the virus as crazy as possible
gain of function involves yes increasing
virality or something but not always to
make it the most right you know it
doesn't mean you're going from zero to
100
maybe you're right from 10 to 15 you
know or 10 to 11. like
what if it was like if this if this
evolves in this way
how do we deal with it in this way and
so
yes there was funding that went to gain
a function of research fauci
lied in this testimony even the even
politifact says
well there was funding from the u.s to
wuhan's lab for gain of function
research and
uh now the story is like maybe the lab
lab league thing is potent is possible
let me pull up some of these things i
pulled up so we got this this is from
april 28 2020.
nih cancels funding for bat coronavirus
research project
the abrupt termination comes at the
research drew president trump's
attention
for its ties to the wuhan institute of
virology
nih was providing funding for bat
coronavirus research at wuhan's
institute of virality that's where the
bat coronavirus came from this is
well we don't we came from we don't know
away from that
right exactly like across the street so
this is
the scientist.com a newsguard certified
source 100 over 100 and i use this
because
if it's wrong don't get mad at me
newsguard said it is the cream of the
crop the best of the best and they
reported this a year before
we have this story from february 25th
2019 human error in high biocontainment
labs a likely pandemic
threat incidents causing potential
exposure to pathogens frequently in high
school
you get the point they talk about a
bunch of stories it's not necessarily
about wuhan the point is
the the likelihood of a lab leak
potentially high
they say human error in high is a likely
pandemic threat
so is it possible that a pathogen leaked
from a lab according to the bulletin.org
i don't know if it's like the bastion of
this one's not newsguard certified
they said they were they reported in
2019 it was when we go over to the
washington post
fact-checking the paul faucy flap over
wuhan lab funding
this is where it gets funny because they
start playing games well it's not
really gain of reap function it's it's
overly verbose
the grant was it was it was more like
dark money it wasn't specifically for
you know uh uh that coronavirus sounds
like [ __ ]
yeah you know when you said he lied i
would be like
he was misleading no he literally i
don't know i mean because like
like from my understanding is that he
defines gain of function research in a
very narrow and lawyerly way
that that's that i'm sorry that's lying
okay how does he do you know how he
defines
with all due respect you're wrong we
have never provided funding for gain of
function research and then you have
politifact
yes they did gain a function research
but fauci is arguing semantics
you know no you know pharma got a lot of
[ __ ]
from everybody for a really long time uh
and you know our public health
authorities were always held in
extremely high esteem like if you
actually looked at that right like
what are people's opinion of the nih cdc
versus what other people's opinion
pharma companies
nih looks like it probably caused the
pandemic and killed a few million people
like or has a has a role i think i think
the lab leak hypothesis is right
um and if not nih then institutional
public health
right right uh and pharma companies
solved it
[Laughter]
right did you see the video from the
white house where they're all hugging
and kissing and like no one's wearing
any masks
no yeah that's new and so i tweeted the
pandemic was over
somewhat facetiously youtube chill i'm
making it point
that the white house nobody was doing
anything
and i mean so there we go i mean the the
taxes in florida have lifted
restrictions obviously a while ago
and now i was recently watching there's
a cnn segment
with fauci and uh chris cuomo and cuomo
was like why aren't there
uh vaccine passports and fauci said
because we can't force people to get the
vaccine
so that means if the guideline is if
you're vaccinated you're okay take your
mask off and these businesses can choose
what they want to do
what else is left people who don't want
to get it aren't going to get it but i
will mention one thing that's really
hilarious
how does it make sense that if you get
the vaccine
you can still get sick but you'll be
asymptomatic like bill maher was
recently
so you'll be able to give people covet
right
if you're that's not my understanding of
the latest sciences that suggests that
it does it's
very not transmissible by people who've
been vaccinated
in the same way make sense of that
before then
then i stand then i will stop right
there and say all right make sense there
you go
so then uh why should people who aren't
vaccinated wear masks
um who aren't vaccinated other people
who aren't vaccinated don't get sick
well i mean like at this point that yeah
i think you're right that there's
that's kind of a weird argument to be
making in general i think once
you know once facts you know math
squaring before was a public health
measure because there's no other measure
available at all to like deal with
spread but like
once everybody has the personal choice
about whether to be vaccinated or not
the value of masks do you know what you
know what's really uh irksome
what the lab leak hypothesis was
published
last year by the washington post and
that was like really the first time i
saw it
there was also stories from the daily
mail and a few others that were asking
these questions
and immediately very left-leaning
democrat media said it's a conspiracy
theory
political politifact for instance
everyone who did that
should be out of a job in a in a
properly functioning media environment
every one of those journalists that
would be like because like think about
are there more important how many more
important questions are there than
how did the pandemic that killed three
million people start
right and you went out there and you
said the theory that actually looks like
the most prominent
was impossible and it debunked
conspiracy theory based on quit
go be a barista do something else and it
like got people's livelihoods destroyed
and like people that would talk about it
online would get shut down
right like lost revenue and things i
agree with you
yeah go be a barista you're not a
journalist anymore like you you're
journalists
maybe we need like professional
licensing for journalists in the same
way that we have i wonder now for
uh lawyers i'll say this anybody out
there who knows anybody who had a strike
or was taken off who was taken down or
suspended for talking about lab leak
should file a a lawsuit against
politifact yeah
there's there's real damages yeah that's
a real yeah actual damages for
defamation right
you know although i mean since it
probably you know
they would say it was specifically
intentionally lying but
yeah reckless disregard for the truth by
claiming that an opinion of a researcher
was a fact
yeah people you've looked it's hard
james o'keefe won that new york times
motion to dismiss he won the motion to
dismiss right which is where the judge
said
i if you're going to insert opinions you
have to say it's an opinion that makes
sense to me
we'll see where it goes from there but
at least he got to that point yeah
so you can't just i think it's defeat us
to be like well they'll probably say no
well i'll file it anyway
you have to be you have to be able to
allege malice right like and and
reckless reckless disregard but reckless
disregard has attack i mean it has a
technical meaning like
you know and that's like that's
ultimately gonna be like conscious
disregard
right so like and proving that's always
going to be very challenging i mean
you got to fight and the o'keeffe case
has the unique thing of like they have
the
timestamp of when the emails were sent
and the
impossibility of comment which is how we
got over um
asserting the problem of asserting males
so all these news outlets
started lying youtube just agreed with
the liars and then negatively impacted
people
and now they're all starting to come
around why is it that conservatives
just buckle so easily well you know we
just don't control the media
and it'd be really nice if we did yeah
the media became more and more
left-leaning and maybe it'll change
you know daily wires doing particularly
well we need to overturn new york times
v sullivan
um it's it's too hard to prove
defamation like the the intense standard
that we've talked about
malice is way because it means you have
to prove someone's
state of mind when they lie wouldn't it
be more reasonable
to just be able to allege defamation
file a suit
say to a judge here's the fact that they
got wrong
and proof and if it's true the judge can
say issue a correction
right and also i mean think about it
from the perspective of like what is
definition right defamation is you've
said something that's injured someone
else's reputation
well the person whose reputation is
injured is an innocent victim had
nothing to do with it
right you just talked about them and
lied about them and said said something
false about them that hurt them that did
them damage
like maybe you should just be liable for
that maybe we shouldn't look at whether
or not you
knew you were lying like maybe you were
or maybe we just have a lower standard
of like negligence like
if you were just if you didn't take
reasonable care and you said something
about someone
that was false and did them dance is it
so hard for the new york times to just
put
apologies we were wrong about this right
like i mean or god forbid they actually
just have to
you know they have a process where their
editors ensure
that whenever they make factual
statements about someone that could
injure their reputation
they take reasonable care yeah right
like they do they act like
reasonable journalists not that they
knowing the standards shouldn't be
did the new york times knowingly lie the
standards should be did they
take reasonable care what we do is we
put the burden
on the uh the plaintiff
so that but we get rid of that standard
so basically make it so that
you have to show the court what you
perceive to be defamation
and evidence to support that that it's
what they said was demonstrably false
only after those two criteria are met
then the person being sued has to
respond
i mean that's kind of the way it works
now right you have to you know allege
um and and basically i mean like do go
step forward and actually presenting
your case of like here's proof to state
that it's an incorrect statement yeah i
mean usually that's
that's done that's the easy part of
defamation right usually when you bring
a defamation case you have that evidence
and honestly like you probably have to
do that and then
if so like if i said something and then
someone filed a suit against me and said
he said you know x equals y but you know
actually it's x equals z then my
response is just
here's an article from the new york
times you know or whatever and here's
the evidence backing that up would that
be sufficient
i mean it would be again probably
because you'd have to show that argue
did you take reasonable care right like
in what reasonable care is going to look
like is probably developed through
judges but we
we know what it looks like in the
context of journalism like did you
research the claim did you try and
verify it was true or false
did you make a good faith effort to do
so if yes then probably it's tough
it is tough you know still it's not it's
it's better it's a lot better than
can you prove that i knew i was lying or
ra that i consciously disregarded
the problem now is the new york times
can lie politifact can lie
and you cannot do anything about it and
it gets put into the record it gets
put into historical record and
encyclopedia and then people end up
believing
insane bs and that's not the way it was
in this country before
new york times b sullivan which
constitutionalized right before that
there was libel law in every
state it totally coexisted with the
first amendment that's not except
until like the the warren court decided
no we're gonna eviscerate
state-level libel law and impose new
federal rules
um and then it's not the way it is in
other countries too right like the
in europe uh especially in england like
libel law sounds a lot more like what i
talked about where
the standard is not did can you prove
they said something false but rather
like
did you take reasonable care yeah i'm
concerned like if
youtubers smack talk each other that one
will get busted
if we repeal times v solomon which i
don't actually know what is it exactly
times b sullivan so times z sullivan is
is the case that sets the standard for
intent in the defamation case
and that's distinct from what you're
talking about like when you're smack
talking that could be
like opinion hyperbole like if it's not
intentionally meant as true then it's
not
something that could be defamatory in
the first place right it has to be like
a false statement
you know put forward for it's true um i
don't know if we got that
exactly right opinions would still be
protected opinions would still be
protected the question is like once
you've demonstrated that somebody said
something false about you
what do you have to prove about their
state of mind right
and if the standard is actual malice you
have to prove
not only that they said something false
but that they knew it was false when
they said it
or that they had what's called reckless
disregard for the truth but that
reckless does a lot of work you have to
prove like
conscious knowledge of or conscious
disregard of things they should have
done
uh potentially in the james o'keefe case
the new york times yeah exactly
they didn't even bother calling the
people to like fact check right they
just said
did james will give his lying it's like
well did you actually look into that no
i don't know he's like we don't that
might get reversed not appeal you know
like that that's just one
state court judge you know we don't we
don't know if that if that ultimately
proves it
whereas again negligence is very common
throughout tort law and that's not
intent like you can just be negligent if
you didn't take reasonable care
so if we repeal times we solve it could
you be negligent and not be held
responsible
well if we if we repeal the times we
sullivan that times you sold instead of
federal
rule for what the intent standard had to
be in defamation cases
repealing it means okay now we're back
to state by state
them themselves figuring out what the
rules should be in defamation cases
and if i'm in texas using a youtube
video where whose
headquarters is in california talking
about someone in north dakota
then are all three states involved
welcome to choice of law
[Laughter]
like that's actually a very con this is
not you know defamation's not the only
area of law there are obviously areas of
law contract law for example
where most things aren't there where
things aren't federalized
in civil litigation and so oftentimes a
question comes up of which states law do
you choose to apply
um and so that's that's very complicated
and each state has their own here's
another
really really big right each state has
their own laws about how to choose which
law applies
in their courts uh well texas and
florida's social media laws will be
interesting
yeah i mean so that actually is an
interesting example of
not quite in the social litigation in
the civil litigation context but
um well maybe uh but yeah like different
states have different laws
and uh you know people will find ways to
especially like one thing that happens i
mean in almost every business contract
if you sign or a lease
you'll notice that there's a choice of
law clause in those leases you sign for
an apartment
that says this this contract will be
governed by the law of
the district of columbia or whatever
right like that's you know because
that's a smart thing to include because
it eliminates that dispute you contract
you can contractually agree to which
state's law applies
yeah well defamation is uh
it's it's probably one of the most
pressing problems that we're facing
right now especially
in cultural politics and politics the
record
as it stands over the past 10 years is
fake
yeah agreed everything
well yeah because the paper of record
was putting out fake news so the record
is fake
the new york times has put out a ton of
fake news like they want awards for it
awards we've lived in the age of
obfuscation
this this there's so many it's a dark
age it really has become kind of there's
so much light that it is blinding us and
we can't see so we might as well be in
the dark and i mean before they screwed
up but at least they tried
you know they had like the new york
times got rid of its public editor
i mean they got rid of their copy
editors they just do they even have fact
checkers anymore
i mean i i assume so but remember when
you used to get a phone call from a fact
checker and they're like hi my name's
john i'm a fact checker with new york
times yeah i got one from the new yorker
a little
a while back new yorker doesn't yeah
they still do it maybe it's just too
expensive to do and so
whatever just let your activist
journalists say whatever i think it
was the new yorker that put out a fake
story about me
where they mashed two quotes together to
make a totally out of context quote
yeah yeah yeah so basically what
happened was a story i told was
offensive
to some people who then threatened i
guess i don't know exactly what happened
but i think they threatened a lawsuit so
the new yorker just wrote what they
wanted them to write
and so then they the new yorker accused
me of giving them erroneous statements
which is obviously false
what happened was a guy at the new
yorker took two different stories
and combined two quotes into one with
like a space so it sounded like
once two separate sentences from 50
minutes apart was one sentence
totally changing the context of what i
had said right and then obviously when
the other
individuals involved in the story saw
that it was lying and making them look
bad which i never said
they told them that's not true i never
said that so then instead of taking
responsibility they said tim poole
provided
erroneous statements so then i called
and said no i didn't
and the journalist told me to go screw
myself he wouldn't correct it
and it was funny because the the issue
was the person that i was the
the the story i was telling involved a
massive
corporation who scared the new yorker
they weren't scared of just one guy
so they you know ultimately just told me
to screw off wow yeah evil
evil people yeah evil not evil
i have so little time for modern
journalism it's so it's so terrible it's
just it's it's maybe the most endlessly
frustrating
it's like because every day you see a
news article and every day you're like
oh
another you know at best misleading
article from you know it's a big part of
why i
am concerned with cancel culture and
canceling because in an age of
propaganda you need
to have access to be able to speak who
you are and and so people can see it
from the
same people policing everybody for
misinformation and heresy
are the same people i mean i i had a
talk of the journalists the other day
and they were like you know talking
about how
no misinformation is a real threat and
i'm like you realize that
your outlets uh put forward a theory
that a billionaire real estate magnate
turned president was really secretly a
russian agent
like think about that for two seconds
that would get laughed out of a
hollywood plot
and yet that that took hold of the
liberal media for three years and was
promulgated by all the
you know the the reputable media outlets
it's just it's a total joke and
you know we have the first amendment in
this country in general the things that
should be protected are you know
statements of opinion about the news
yeah
like it's one thing to say like i mean i
think we should be much stricter when it
comes to defamatory content
you say something false about a person
that hurts them that injures them you
should be held liable let's
let's play a game public debate wild
west
let's play a game andrew marantz of the
new york times
i'm sorry of the new yorker mish-mashed
two quotes of mine from two
it was it was a one long story with
different chapters per se
and he took one quote and one quote he
mashed them together
it was about vice verse took issue
with the statement provided so in order
to avoid
my response marantz or someone added to
the article
quote an earlier version of this article
included a quotation from tim poole
concerning vice news's coverage in
ferguson
the quotation has been removed because
it contained several errors
that's vague it sounds like the errors
were mine
it was a quotation provided with errors
in it the quotation
was theirs andrew marantz wrote a fake
story
because in my opinion he's a liar
who realized he could make a salacious
juicy story by mashing quotes together
for the new yorker
and the new yorker published fake news
and i'll add one more to it
there's another story from the new
yorker which they pressured us
and tried to publish fake news and they
embellished this most insane story about
me and my friend
we get a call from a fact checker and
they're asking us outrageous stupid
things
and i'm like all of these are
exaggerations and they're like yeah come
on come on come on they're like
they're they're they're uh asking me you
sleep in a closet don't you what and i
was like no it's a it's a box car you
know you know
you know the box the railway apartments
in new york where it's like you got to
walk through one room to get to the next
yeah but it's like a closet and i was
like it has a window
no no but you know what i mean like it's
like i was like sure it's like a closet
i guess
or something that effect that's the new
yorker they write fake news
andrew marantz is a liar do not trust
him
he writes fake stories and he will smear
you here's what
statement of fact wait here's what
marantz wrote about me in his book
let's see here talking to chamberlain
about politics felt a bit like talking
to a young earth creationist about
dinosaurs
i considered some of his core beliefs
for example that donald trump should be
trusted with a nuclear arsenal
to be irrational almost to the point of
incomprehensibility
but once we had agreed to disagree on a
few core premises we could start to have
a conversation
his goal the whole time was to
pretend that because he had access he
was writing the truth
instead what he did was he came to my
apartment and i thought he recorded the
whole thing
and i like excellent and so the story
was very simple
i said on one night i did x on another
night i did x and they did y
he combined those to make it seem like
vice failed to do something on a
particular night which resulted in
a failure for the company i can't get
into this too much of the specifics you
can read the story i suppose
uh vice got mad about it they were like
that's [ __ ]
that never happened and so and he
wouldn't correct that's so embarrassing
well you see what they wrote
you see what he wrote it contained
errors he didn't say
they're they're very they're they're
weasley this is what the media does do
not
trust these organizations take a look at
uh uh
there was man i don't want to get too
much into it take a look at what lauren
southern has been posting about the
smear piece about her they're they're
they're i i am surprised
how often these conservative
personalities are like these journalists
are cool i trust them
why they're going to lie about you
do not give them money it's like what
they say with the police
you don't have to say anything you know
you have a right to remain safe yeah i
know i i
said i talked to that journalist
yesterday i had like some journalists
call me and ask me about like the
the trump you know the poll watcher
video i was like i'll just answer
questions
you know i almost do it like maybe i'll
you know maybe i'll be hurt but also
at some point i actually like putting
things on the record with that and now
now you know what they can do
what you let's explain to you guys how
it works let's say you get a phone call
from a journalist like hey i was
wondering i would ask you a question
about the video you posted it was a
video about a dog doing a backflip and
you're like
oh yeah yeah i was walking down the
street and i saw a dog do a backflip
what do you want to know
oh what kind of dog was it uh i think it
was a german shepherd pretty big for a
dog doing a back flip interesting
interesting
and how did you feel about it it's all
right i guess okay thank you
well have a nice day then the article
comes out i called will chamberlain to
ask about a video he posted and he was
immediately agitated and aggressive
i was kind of put off by his anger and
animosity but nonetheless i decided to
ask him the question anyway
fair point why did you film the dog
immediately a response scared me
he seemed angry at the dog almost
violent and i was concerned he would
actually hurt dogs in the future
when he explained to me as a german
shepherd i could hear the hatred in his
voice
i think this man is violent and
dangerous and needs to be arrested
immediately before he hurts an animal
and then as soon as you say that's not
true they're all opinions
and do you have the phone call recorded
that's true i didn't record this one i
should have
so what do you do when they lie about
you when you get on the phone with
someone
you give them the ability to say i spoke
with them on the phone
and this is how i felt swipe no
no don't answer i always do everything
over email and writing that's smart
that's smart that's probably i should
have done this because then i can just
publish the emails and be like but they
can still say in the email they were
furious
i was shocked they were they're threats
of i felt unsafe
the emotions i felt when i read that
text those scratches on that wall
yeah blame the author liberal that's
actually a good
general practice like liberal outlets
can send you written questions
i was going to say i think there's too
many news organizations but i don't want
it to centralize into the
hands of a few so maybe it's good you
know you know you know what i do
when i get emails from like liberal
organizations i respond with a statement
like
you know um uh
the the writers on january 6 should be
in prison
and that's my response smart so it's
like what are they going to say
well we asked him about whether or not
he was a fan of bitcoin and he said the
writers should be in prison
[Laughter]
jail that's just the jail meme yeah
right they'll still try and play games
so you gotta be careful they'll say with
an unrelated and nonsensical statement
or something authoritarian
he responded with a white supremacist
slogan because that's an opinion
that's why you make the news you are the
news that's why we make videos
and you put yourself online because no
one can twist that yet
deep fakes are coming ian we we talk
about how history is written by the
victors and at least for me i always
thought about that in the instance of
like war
and wars being fought that is not the
case history has been written by the
victors it has been written by people
who won
the culture war and they are shaping the
way that people think now and the
direction that we're pointing now
it's a huge problem and i don't think
that we saw it coming or respected it
when we should have
let's uh let's jump over to super chats
oh yeah it's uh you have not already
give a little little little tap to that
like button because it seriously does
help but more importantly always
sharing the the video is is massive um
there was someone who posted the metrics
and they were like look what happens new
share and it's like it just
that's how we're gonna actually i mean
maybe it's not perfect
but it helps us in the work we do when
you share and it spreads
the ideas to people who might not have
them you maybe you know someone and
you're like they just don't understand
well maybe they haven't seen an episode
of tim cast
smash the like button go to timcast.com
we are going to have
i'm not kidding you you are absolutely
going to love
the upcoming bonus segment because it's
going to be a wild ride
of crazy conspiracies donald trump from
the future time traveling and a whole
bunch of crazy stuff
it's going to be fun and silly but
you're going to want to hear this stuff
because uh
i mean there's some really weird stories
and and this stuff isn't relatively new
but we're going to go through these
crazy conspiracies that look at real
things that make people say how is that
possible
time travel that's right anyway that's
right
some super chats stay tuned go team
guest account become a member
make 1984 fiction again says just your
weekly reminder that total deaths per
capita in the us has not changed in 10
years
including last year but hey let's
destroy the economy and redefine our
culture and society for it now
that came from a john hopkins op-ed
beneficial data but i don't think that's
correct i think yeah excess deaths were
up they were yeah yeah so there was
another there was a global pandemic
but right right but here's what happened
there was a there was an article written
by a doctor for i believe it was john
hopkins university
you know page blog or whatever right
that show data point saying that it
didn't go up
and then it was immediately challenged
by a bunch of people
i just got to say this when i see one
story say one thing and like
a thousand say something else showing
data points i understand we just went on
this big rant about media lying that's
why i try to look in aggregate and try
and track the data myself
so i'll look at these institutions there
was one story that said they weren't up
and i'm like i don't think that's that's
that's good
i think i don't remember exactly what
his name is lyman stoneski but he always
had really good charts on twitter
that were showing excess deaths and i
mean excess deaths were up there they
were up everywhere
uh not only that but it's interesting
that someone would assert they weren't
when we have stories of violent crime
skyrocketing and murders being up
so if murders are going up wouldn't that
indicate the numbers should be up i
guess you could try and argue maybe the
car accidents are down too because
you know like that's a big contributor
to deaths as well right like there was
and apparently there were like way fewer
for example like child injuries
like they were holding part of what
happened as a result of pandemic is like
those wards got crushed in the hospitals
now here's something i care about
rampton says what do y'all think about
nicole arbour feuding with candace owens
over cancel chrissy teigen
and walking off candace's panel on her
show this week i don't care
i don't know was the argument that
chrissy teigen shouldn't be cancelled
is i mean i don't know i will assume
that there
i i will try and make the best argument
that a coalitive made which is that we
should stick by the principle of not
cancelling people
because you know we should be the
principal side blah blah blah blah
and uh say that no we don't unilaterally
disarm like if
i disagree you don't think so i think
the right needs to be the side of
uncancelling
uh if all you do is say stop
then they're going to keep taking ground
i don't know i think you i think you
have to be
i think a bit more from a deterrence
perspective right like they they
they must make them live up to their own
book of rules fire with fire
oh you're saying so we should cancel
them right like you should cancel the
cancelers right like if p you know the
people probably getting
right anybody promulgating canceled
culture should be
forced to play by their own rules oh of
course of course right but i think on
the other side
additionally the right needs to be the
party of actively
uncancelling people sure i absolutely
agree bringing back milo
and laura loomer oh yeah like i think
you know
you know i don't even like laura loomer
and i think we should bring her back
she's
she has a right she's american citizen
has a right to speak exactly every you
know
even you know people i remember i was
talking with some tech bro who's trying
to explain to me why
he and i actually agreed about uh
censorship policy when we didn't
you know he was it's like a super
villain in a movie being like you know
bond you and i are a lot of like
right right we're not you're a villain
he's trying to say like this is actually
like a communications decent
like a cd different thing about
copyright and i'm like no no
no i here's what i want i want you to
have the same right to speak
in a public park that you do same right
to speak on facebook and twitter that
you do in a public park that's what i
want
and he said but there's a lot of really
nasty speech on facebook and twitter and
i was like
yes yep that's also the balance struck
by our first amendment there's a lot of
nasty speech that's protected
yeah right like this is this is not a
technocratic disagreement we have a
values difference
um all right let's see we got eric babb
says nothing biden does is surprising
anymore
after hearing him say we the people
while the people are the government
so according to biden we are a nation of
the government by the government for the
government
i i i i will say you know the one really
compelling thing that biden has
has said before was shoulda shot a
pressure mm-hmm
better did he get us that yet so you
know the phrase the banality of evil
from hannah rent yeah there's a banal
awfulness to the bible frustration
that's true right what does that mean
banal so like
boring pedestrian
evil refers to how people just
mindlessly followed orders
like willful ignorance willfully
ignorantly no no no no
no no not like just just sort of
passively you know
accepting accepting of of you know awful
policy right like the classic example is
that like we open the show with the
discussion of the smuggling children
like
that is just like there's not some you
know evil cackling person in the
background there's just like
oh how do we get this off the news
because all the kids in cages photos are
bad
i guess i guess we just put them on
planes and hide them you know what i
should do
what eventually i should run for a
president and i should grow out a twirly
mustache
oh no and then i'll run as a democrat
though and i'll be like
and then we'll strip the pension funds
and claim we're giving people health
care
the system will burn down democrats want
to
want to reinstate the salt cap have you
followed that at all i love this
right it's literally like the it would
be the most regressive thing it would be
the most enormous cat tax cut to like
hedge fund managers in new york and
california and venture capitalists
um and democrats should be opposed to
like bernie is but democrats are like
we need a middle class salt cap to cut
and it's just
like you guys are so transparent i want
to be on the debate stage
and when they're like how many of you
are in favor of open borders or
decriminalizing border crossings and
they all raise their hands
i'll be like excellent and then we'll
use them for cheap labor under
the table so that we displace the
working class and strip them of their
value
like say their policies are a good thing
but explain why they're bad as the
villain guy
i'll wear it i'll wear a top hat and
i'll have like a monocle and a cane and
and then i'll be like excellent
excellent ah the koch brothers they must
be celebrating the idea of the industry
getting cheap they literally are they
that is exactly right
you could do that and then make a video
on youtube and your video would get more
views than the debate yeah
maybe actually that's a great idea to
like green screen yourself into the
debate
yeah and when they say something like
you know in california
when they're like how many of you are in
favor of giving free health care to
illegal immigrants and they all raise
their hand
be like and then american citizens who
have paid for 20 years
won't be able to get healthcare
and then i could have like a group of
like henchmen behind me wearing like
weird suits with like goggles and gas
masks
that's the plan man yes otherwise i'm
here for it
we need to hire like a production crew
so we can do these skits and just make a
skit channel or something
i also want to hire a patent lawyer all
right i just have ideas
i could probably get somebody for you
okay cool lawyers are cheap right well
no
yeah they're not what if i paid him a
percentage of the money the patents make
in perpetuity
all right a sea lion in orange says the
democrats
are the beth monster and the republicans
are the jerry monster from that one
episode of rick and morty
have you seen that i've never seen an
episode of the beth monster is
basically so it's basically beth and
jerry the two people they they go
and then this machine makes like their
mental version of themselves so jerry
how he sees his wife and how his wife
sees him
married he sees his wife as the the the
alien from alien
and she sees him as a slug going and
then she takes him and uses him and
it's hilarious well the whole point is
that they're codependent and they
require each other to survive and he's
like this spineless sniveling little
slug and she's this overpowering
domineering woman because she's a mental
image of how he sees her
so yeah i could see it no no no no
kyle miller says let's storm the timpool
compound he doesn't have enough 50 bmg
to stop us all
also lydia can you please say aura aura
why
i don't i don't trust that but uh let me
just assure you
i do have enough 50 bmw we're good
there's there's there's very clear signs
that say trespassing will be prosecuted
on the way my mom got me a sign that
says uh trespassers will be shot and
survivors will be prosecuted
[Laughter]
survivors will be prosecuted we're not
putting it up we'll put it downstairs
somewhere
i'm surprised to be shot again it's a
joke it's not real
oh yeah potato masher says does anyone
know what freedom is
just some thoughts freedom is the
ability obviously to take your pants off
on the stage of the libertarian debates
heck yeah freedom is the right to sell
heroin to children
yes freedom to a prisoner is the ability
to walk around and see the sun any time
of day
so it's kind of relative seth alvarez
says tim if you're angry at rep
politicians
invite one on to your show surely
there's there's some who would have a
conversation with you
wasn't parnell on last night yes okay
literally he's been on several times but
he didn't get
in yet uh okay so yeah elected official
he's running for senate
and i like the guy so i i i hope he does
win and i'm glad he's willing to come on
the show and have these conversations
but uh you know every time i message uh
someone they say
what yes email this person
yeah and then i say okay and then you
you know that person says when we email
them
nothing yep
there's a lot of people that i've
reached out to
that say yes politicians are the worst
that sounds like an actor sounds like
you're dealing with that you could
probably get ken buck on
i bet you could get ken colorado yeah
because i know he's chief of staff so
that's that solves the staff problem
i don't i'm you know i got to be honest
if someone refers me to
a staff member i'm just not going to
bother emailing them at all
if i can dm you i've dm'd probably like
four or five republicans
and i'm like yo we can take care of
here's the plan here's what we want to
do are you interested and they say yes i
say
we're good figure out your schedule let
me know it's no problem right we're on
dm now
no they they pass me off i say okay just
say no next time i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna waste my time
i think that's just a function of how
their offices work there's a guardian of
the schedule
in a way that like you know politicians
yeah maybe maybe you don't have to waste
your time you're i mean it's just this
is where yes minister comes in right
like the
the whole point of these little officers
and all these little underlings is
they control you know rand paul come on
the show we're big fans
whenever we're like all politicians suck
we're like randy's okay no ran's off
top cop thomas massey tom cotton josh
ran i mean on the show yeah yeah here's
such good things about josh holley
doesn't he he's like a homesteader no uh
that's thomas matthew oh
yeah yeah i got all these names mixed up
yeah yeah
thomas massey and rand paul are like at
the top yeah yeah
that's cool yeah but there's like what
ten
republicans we gotta need a new party i
don't know we're working on it
more good
these terrestrial snails starfish and
jellyfish
in the republican party who support the
democrats need to be voted out
i marry them primary them you can't even
vote you have to vote someone else i've
never seen any of them
on any republican news show
podcast anything like every one of those
republicans is like
a creature of the nrcc and has
who ted cruz has a podcast with myself
oh no no but i'm talking about the ones
who voted no right other than like liz
i've never heard of it there's like some
of them go on like lib media right like
cheney and kenzinger and whoever
but none of the 35 they were all these
just anonymous republican congress
people who've never been on a republican
program
yes primary it's time kristen f says
went to a local brewery in northwest
indiana this past weekend
and overheard a couple talking about the
latest tim poole episode
feels good knowing there are others in a
predominantly democratic area
aware of good independent media i
actually think
the opinions that we have on the show
mostly like me and doing my show
resonate with chicagoans because that's
probably from being in chicago
in our metrics we can see that the
largest the location for with the most
views is chicago oh it's awesome
interesting i wonder if it's i've talked
about this before
you grow up in a city that's been run by
democrats for 80 years there's no
qualm with republicans because they're
not relevant to the local conversation
you just keep getting democrats who make
everything worse and people keep voting
for it eventually all you're saying is i
hate democrats
you're not a republican you're a
moderate liberal but the democrats in
your city i just have a stranglehold and
they're destroying everything i can talk
about
when the mayor came down to my local
park and was like we're going to build
y'all a skatepark and we're like yay
photo up and then
his gun never comes back i hate them all
never built the skate park
no they built there was already a trash
park there and they were going to make
like a good one they said
as a photo op to go out and pretend like
you helped the kids or something a
little weird you know that's funny i
i lived i grew up in cupertino
california i've been around democrats
lived in democrat areas my entire life
except for like a
six months stint in boise idaho uh
and i feel like that almost that made me
like
i like some if you actually look at just
my actual policy views
they're pretty moderate but in terms of
attitudinally and like
what team i'm on i'm like i want
republicans to win i want i think it's
very important that they do
and i'd prefer democrats not to win and
i just wish there was something other
than republicans man
dave smith with the libertarian party
that's like
this is a big deal he's he runs for
president and i don't even know if he's
who knows i've never seen a libertarian
win the president but
abraham lincoln was uh built a fourth
party to win his
republican election created the
republicans dude if we get hard behind
dave he goes
it's just about oh whoa whoa the process
let's read some more super chats
wolf's black roses i didn't know will
was anti-second amendment
his anti-crypto argument is a page out
of the gun grabbers handbook
hmm that's actually that's an
interesting rejoinder um i am pro second
amendment by the way sorry just to make
that clear
like criminals use guns criminals
criminals do use guns
uh but that's a constitutional right and
it's also important to self defense i
think that
you know your ability to defend yourself
against violence from
knives or punching or whatever is a
basic right and that's what about my
ability to defend myself from
inflationary currency
uh defend yourself from inflation
currency well
not a constitutional right and there's a
collective action problem there
with like if you you know the the
consequence of not having
having a currency that is not possible
to dilute is
uh things like uh the 2009 crisis
all right newa haking says i live in
logan square chicago and on the way home
last night there were signs calling a
woman and her husband out by name
photos defining characteristics and
social media usernames directly calling
them neo-nazis
geez creepy and it would have been
vandalism to rip those signs down
no i don't think i don't think so yeah i
don't
unless you had like a right to put them
up for some reason
sonny james says i love the jewish
people but statist secular jews have
misinterpret misrepresented them
to the point since i've openly
criticized zionism my super chats are
carefully monitored and impossible to
get through
to be canceled soon don't tell me i'm
the only one
so wait is this like are you saying that
your
anti-zionist jews get cancelled is that
the argument
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i'm confused whatever
jurassic josh says timothy poole the u.s
not negotiating with terrorists is a
quote from a harrison ford movie
it is not an actual stance of the us
government grow up stop lying to your
viewers
that's weird when i did the hostile
environment training they specifically
said the us doesn't negotiate with
terrorists
sometimes they like in a general sense
i'm sure in certain circumstances there
are i think he's talking about air force
one did you guys see that movie harrison
plays the president he like punches a
guy in the face we don't deal
negotiate with terrorists have you seen
that no it's a great movie
commander 232 says well to give you a
bit of positive news myself and my
comrades in federal protective services
walk off when we were tasked to help
with the smuggling of the illegal
immigrants no way for real
that true story good for you yeah wow
good for you happy to hear it
all right let's see what we got here
sonny james says so what the heck
difference does it make if you have all
the crypto in the world if the
government seizes your assets
for the ever-growing crime uh list such
as racism
and the old conspiracy charge no crypto
can help you the why islands are risky
by
that uh is not true crypto can be stored
in your brain
you can remember 10 words and have
access to your crypto forever
and they can't seize it it's impossible
the blockchain exists decentralized
around the planet
they can arrest you they can demand it
and then as soon as i mean sure they can
lock you and throw away the key
they can do that regardless but
remembering it's ten words right
yeah something like that it ranges
sometimes it'll be eight sometimes i
think 16. it depends on the service and
it'll be like dog
run car fly airport theater
pizza yeah and then that's your that's
it you remember those 10 words and then
you can log in and access
your your crypto from wherever you want
they can't take it away
they can't seize it until they uh they
can have a brain with a neural net
and start trying to read your memories
and your thoughts or like take
bamboo and shove up your fingernails or
whatever nothing is forever nothing's
permanent and nothing is stable we're
always
at risk but i think crypto's a lot less
risky than
fiat at the moment all right tag says
the problem with the gold standard is
develo the development of asteroid
mining
once one of the reasons gold has value
is because it's rare
once asteroid mining gets off the ground
gold will no longer be rare
i don't know i mean that's actually
literally the opposite of my point the
problem is
the fixed supply you know having your
own national currency be something
that's not under your control can lead
to
recessions because of the problem of
wage stickiness like if you're
if your country becomes less productive
you have the choice of either diluting
your currency
you know or your currency floating
against others or wage cuts everybody
hates wage cuts so if you actually
choose that what you're really choosing
is mass unemployment
brandon d says ian read your personal
crypto idea
read the unincorporated man not exactly
one to one but irrelease similar oh
thanks
tiz said tim look up look up wyckoff
distribution
distribution theory it just happened to
bitcoin the big institutions are now
manipulating the market
perhaps i've warned about that as well
mount romer says hack seems suss
government hates monero
could be a win-win for them more private
coins too
like pirate govs do shady deals
themselves
banning never makes it go away but makes
it more valuable
didn't a bunch of like feds steal silk
road bitcoin
that was like i would guess they would
seize it as an asset no no they got
arrested they went to jail or something
oh yeah was it like was it uh you know
because obviously the guy who
made it i guess they were responsible
for the silk roads in jail yeah
something happened
um he got convicted pirate roberts yeah
right and so uh so like yeah russell
rick that's right so the
the prosecutor or the police officers on
the case like stole some bitcoin
yeah like 750 million dollars worth or
billion dollars
a lot of money and it was like two in
march or something i think this happened
yeah it's not the first time cops have
stolen drug money i don't know they
seized it i don't know when they got
they got caught in march i think well if
they seized it it would be illegal they
just stole it
right seizing is something the
government's allowed to do when you but
like
personally
sean kent says tim you need to form a
coalition with the likes of the
intellectual dark web and other
prominent anti-woke people
make an llc media organization to rival
the legacy media
get collaboration with big time players
get enough momentum rival youtube
i am not a big fan of the intellectual
dark web that's about it
i personally don't like cliques in
general i like those people though yeah
like closed groups well i guess like
we're this now
look how we are expensive and they fell
apart like they're not they don't they
don't even hang out anymore
like they what if it was a click like
they don't like
reuben and sam harris you'll notice they
don't really go on each other's show
brett weinstein
is legit i like brett a lot i like
characters i like
i like all these people as intellectuals
sometimes i think they
are wrong especially when it comes to
matters of political strategy
i think they often get it wrong on that
question brian scanlon says charles
hodgson hoskinson the creator of the
cryptocurrency cardano said in a recent
ama
that he would like to come on the show
you guys should reach out to him cardano
is an amazing project there's nobody
better to answer all of your crypto
questions
we have did you message him on twitter i
can't message him on twitter
but i have reached out to him on a
couple different occasions telling him
to get in touch with me because i do the
guests for ira
cool so and the ball is in his court
hopefully soon
all right let's see what we got here
someone posting some
what is this some nonsense
oh okay i don't know do to do
let's see let's grab a good one
everyone's just basically saying crypto
is the best will is wrong
not surprised it's like the inverse of
the last episode where i was like
everyone's like tim's you're wrong i'm
like jail riders everybody's like yay
crypto bad what we're gonna go ahead
all right let's just see we'll grab a
couple more down at the the latest ones
because
youtube jumped on us and it's all right
let's see we got
joshua vogt says hello tim from from a
air force
military police vet thinking of running
for mayor of my town in a couple of
years
it super left us for the longest time
i'm not currently working pest control
love y'all
there you go that's cool danine says you
keep mentioning paypal and stripe can i
just pay with a card
i don't know anything about stripe but
after my mom died paypal made it
impossible for me to close her account
i'm not doing paypal
when you click stripe to become a member
it literally just asks for
your credit card information it's like
super easy to do it's awesome
stripe is really fantastic great service
super excited to have them integrated
but again
you click sign up to be a member and it
just says credit card information you go
boom
done well there's probably a little bit
more involved in that but it's
it's relatively easy sean kent says also
can i submit skit ideas for you
i have a free one here sjw chess player
goes to get a bank loan and puts two
pennies on the counter
teller says sir two pennies is not
enough sjw did you just assert assume
my currency's value hey there you go
that's like that's the next yeah okay
yeah my currency is value
gabriel martinez says tim first time
commenting you would win on a republican
ticket do it
also currency and money are two
different things gold is money the
dollar is currency now
bitcoin is the new gold you would if
you're not i don't think so
republican you'd win nothing i don't i
don't really think there's a meaningful
difference between money and currency
unless you have a
narrower definition of currency that's
like state run or something
no the the the conservatives i i
disagree on policy on a lot of these
policies that's why you would win
vote for someone you disagree with it's
an ever encroachment to the left just
because i don't like them
if they like if they like you that's why
they vote
oh yeah i guess and i'd be i'd have a
really easy time of fundraising
yeah i wouldn't need the fundraise yeah
wow yeah if
like you know sean came on this you know
on the show and he's talking about the
need to fundraise and i'm like
i don't need to that's the way the game
works though i guess you know
the people who run big companies and
make a ton of money can easily just run
for office
got to make a bunch of promises but the
more important thing is that the amount
of media play i could get from my own
work is
way more than they could buy dude if we
did well the the
new york times would like high end smear
that'd be so fun weren't there some
brazilian
youtubers who got elected yeah that's
what i heard
because they that they control a lot of
the media you know yeah
so while while these other candidates
are desperately trying to buy media
i just turn the camera on and say yo
what up would you guys be down to paint
the white house
because the world think you can just do
that well if we're the president if
you're the president can i
i don't think you can get like taxpayer
support yeah
he's going to run on a platform of
tradition
but because the romans my my my
republican platform would be
insane good huh i i was yeah so if i ran
for president
it would be awesome yeah i know i feel
like i'm going to pardon like everybody
basically like not
like all non-violent offenders like
we'll go through
where there's like victimless crimes
drugs and abuse and stuff like that
just to start rubber stamping it
especially federal gun crimes that are
non-violent
boom boom boom boom marijuana oh you
betcha boom boom just just
cranking them all out pardoning
everybody like crazy the first day
i just be like give me the list i'm
pardoning them all send them home
we got too many people in prison for
dumb things stop wasting money
and then the taxpayers don't got to
waste that money so we'll lower taxes
how much money can we save by pardoning
you know all nonviolent offenders i mean
philly's trying this experiment
non-violent defenders yeah cause like
think about it people plead
right like they're non-violent offenders
don't go to jail for as much
we've talked about this before the
review would involve
would not include anybody who pled down
from
violent crimes okay that's right okay
so the file says this person was accused
of doing sync and then they pleaded this
charge i'd be like sorry
but if it's like some some guy was
chilling on his stoop with a you know
with a 40 and his friends and
you know he got arrested i'd be like get
out of here or if it was like a guy was
selling like marijuana or something i
beg now or if a guy was like he had a
suppressor and he didn't follow the nfa
i'd
not get out of here like you're free to
go you're free to go second amendment
free to go free to go
a lot of stuff pretend the constitution
like that that's probably the only thing
i would do i'd say like i'm gonna go
through
every single federal case and
anything on constitutional grounds
pardon
we need less law so i'm down with that
like you got a story about a guy who's
like chilling in his house and the cops
like
kick the door without a warrant or
whatever and then like he fought with
him and then they charged him i'd be
like oh
he's going free oh even though he fought
but it was self-defense
there's a lot of there's a lot of creepy
stories like that you know so i'd
probably
err on the side of freedom which could
be a little bad i know conservatives
wouldn't like that you know what i mean
yeah i know i think the whole like free
all the prisoners uh
is not a traditional conservative policy
proposal
yeah hey you want to lower taxes right
yeah
well then how about the guy who was like
non-violent offender who was like
minding his own business smoking pot
shouldn't be in prison i mean
i think most conservatives would agree
with there you go we're going to save
you money
that guy can go home and he can smoke
all the potty wands i don't care
why should you pay to lock that guy up
because he was rocking a ganja in his
basement
that's stupid i mean i just don't really
think very many people are in jail for
that
honestly no but it would like in federal
crimes it would be more than just like a
guy in his basement it would be like you
know
trafficking or selling or something but
i don't care i think it's stupid people
should be in jail for that nonviolent
defenses
uh it's it's not so simple i'd also run
on unlike
executive order instructing the atf to
stop doing all their jobs
like you will now be allowed to play
video games all day and just don't do
anything else
right yeah just the rubber rooms you
know they had you know what the do you
know where that comes from i'm kidding
by the way because
they they still do things that that are
in the new york teachers union they
literally they have things called rubber
rooms which is where they put the
teachers they can't fire
it's called a rubber room because we
play a rubber of bridge
the game the card game oh right like so
they're expected to sit around playing
no i'd
i i'd be like focus on firearms i'm
sorry i'm sorry focus on
explosives sorry it's alcohol alcohol
tobacco firearms and explosives i'd be
like ignore the firearm stuff and just
focus on the explosives so they'd love
to do that that's like the fbi's
favorite thing to do they find some
radical and then they're like oh we'll
just
insert an undercover agent and offer to
sell them explosives no i got a better
idea
i'd make them like actually enforce the
law against far-left extremists
yeah that's sorry jail jail
right to jail right dude the reason i
want to be at the white house
and i'm joking because the roman where
we got this architecture from the white
marble pillars and stuff all the roman
architecture is white marble pillar
because the paint faded away
they painted that stuff the statues
these white marble stitches were painted
they looked normal first last says we
should make
ian's white party i disagree
do you do you know the story i do not
know the story
so ian said that there should be a new
white party
in the states or whatever and everyone
and like i can't remember it was like me
little
there's red there's blue there's white
red white and blue yeah
yeah yeah and there's red states there's
blue states what if there are white
states red white and blue and they're
like yeah he says he said we need white
states we're like no
no no you could you could interpret that
in the monarchy sense because white was
traditionally the color of the
monarchies and like the french
revolution
you could go that like you know i'm
gonna back off like old school
reactionary angle if you want
because the alternative is not good no i
don't think we need political parties
my friends we've got a crazy
crazy conspiracy that's going to be a
whole lot of fun a lot of laughs
time travel the secrets of the alternate
timelines
oh we're gonna talk about all of this
and there's an actual news story that
i'm gonna bring up and you're gonna
laugh and it's gonna be hilarious
so make sure you go to timcast.com and
become a member because we're gonna have
fun with this one
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram at tim cast irl you can share
our videos on facebook
helps grow the channel and then you know
we try to leverage that to get more
viewers and
people on the website we're really
focusing on getting people on the
website
so we're going to be also hosting things
on rumble
moving forward it's going to be really
awesome uh so definitely make sure to
check us out when we do the show monday
friday live
at 8pm you can follow me personally at
timcast basically everywhere
and uh sign up at timecast.com leave us
a good review you want to shout anything
out will
yeah um i mean human events guys again
if you weren't here at the beginning
we hired jack besobic we're really
stoked on it i mean he's going to be
doing
like podcasts and and stuff and we're
going to so we're going to be uh
i'm really excited about future human
events we have a big investor in
brought in jack like there's more coming
that's big awesome
uh you can follow me at iancrossland.net
and that at ian crossland all across
social media
thanks for coming i love you guys bye
you guys can follow me on twitter at
sour patch lids in my journey to have
more followers and sour patch kids
that'll be fun we will see you over at
timcast.com video should be up around 11
or a little bit before after thanks for
hanging out we'll see you then bye guys
you